hi hey everybody what's going on welcome
to the team coco plus xbox live gaming
event we are here live
in venice california uh at the what is
this place called the xbox house the
microsoft uh beach house i'm not sure
but we're at this awesome celeb studded
party let's get a shot of it right now
[Music]
and uh i know it looks like we're in the
corner but yes there's all kinds of
people gaming playing a bunch of really
exciting xbox games all right come back
to us that's enough of those
celebs this is the real action here
we're uh with michael de plata yep all
right exactly creative director of
shadow of war which is extremely
exciting it's never been streamed before
so uh over the next two hours we're
going to be playing a lot of shadow of
war we're going to play some forwards of
seven we'll play some crackdown three
we're gonna play some uh artful escape
and we're gonna be taking your questions
the entire time with all sorts of people
so all right michael explain to us uh
this is a sequel to shadow of mordor yep
i'm completely after that guy
immediately after seconds after that
game ends we start this so italian is
our main character italian and keller
brimbo and keller brimbur who's the uh
kind of ring uh he that's how that's why
you have all these ring powers like the
ring wing right yes excellent all right
so uh let's get going let's play a
little bit okay cool so what we're going
to do
um this is the army screen so this is
sauron's army
and we can go in here and we can pick a
target all of these guys are going to be
completely unique you know we've never
seen any of them before and that's
really cool so this is and you're this
is one of the coolest things i like
about this game which is
if you guys play this game you will have
uh different enemies than we'll than we
do if we play this game twice we'll have
different enemies each time yeah so
orthodog the elder a warmonger assassin
that's we only get ortho yeah and uh we
were playing a little bit earlier and
this guy named bork
is my arch enemy but unfortunately bork
since he's dying this game is dynamic i
won't be able to find bork in this game
will i so i'm gonna have to
a new arch enemies
there we go there we go exactly
dark lord daschle good to see you what's
up jacob sarkis hello hello and hello to
mixer facebook
youtube uh we are all over the place
we're streaming everywhere is that who
else are we where's ah and twitch of
course our positive twitch
so by the way that's the exact same way
i jump i do a little pirouette in the
air it's the elfiness that's it that's
right hey carrie noir what's up
that's right shadow of war guys if you
have questions by the way michael's the
guy the creative director of the game i
can't play and talk at the same time
that's my i'll talk about that's my
weekend and then i'll take over i'll
take it okay
so what we're going to do the orcs are
actually going on missions they're going
about their business they're living in
this world yeah so um the orc we're
going to hunt down here he's actually
doing a trial by ordeal so the way orcs
prove themselves that's basically just
caught that's a monday morning for me
it's a trial boy ordeal involving ghouls
presumably again monday morning cool i'm
sorry everyone i work with that conan
uh crackhorn the brave
they've got these guys caged out good
lord in order to get his next promotion
he's got to face his fears survive this
ordeal everybody's going to rank up but
we're going to use that ambush him um
and take him down too oh i love him this
is great situation and i love fighting
dirty by the way so i i'm oh oh he got
to board that did not go very well for
him those guys those guys did our job
for us that's fantastic
oh my god the ghouls thanks schools
it's amazing well done all right
so that i'm not going to play it yes
everybody beth is here too she's in the
corner she's not allowed on the stream
just so you know actually what i'm gonna
do
oh sorry my voice is breaking that's
okay that's okay ridiculous karaoke
i know right so you've been this has
been a a long e3 for you you were saying
that's been awesome though that's right
this is great how long has this game
been in development we are three years
now so wow we ship shadow motor and from
the second we finished that wow hard at
work on this oh my gosh that's crazy
basically everything we learned in the
first game every crazy feature we wanted
to add everything people wish for
what are some of the things that you're
most excited about to show fans of
shadow of mordor uh in shadowhorn uh
actually this is good that you asked
look at this fortress assaults there's a
there's a few things that relate to them
one okay they're these huge epic battles
so if you see the battle of helms deep
in the two towers yes uh return of the
king it's really what all this epic
fantasy is about absolutely it's getting
the epic in there
and uh two
we've taken the nemesis system where
everybody's enemies followers they're
all these totally unique characters and
we've applied that to the world as well
it's not just the characters that are
unique well so this fortress where we
can see all the the skulls all of these
yes that's because the overlord the guy
ruling this fortress is from the mystic
tribe so they actually affect not just
the characters but the wow that's insane
good lord so it's just random that this
fort looks exactly like my apartment
it's exactly the decor everything it was
basically when you walk in you walk
through a bunch of dragon teeth it's
amazing and so how many and what and uh
you told me before but what are the
different tribes so these guys the the
mystic tribe they're into a lot of dark
magic sorcery sacrifice the feral tribe
hunters and killers of all the wild
beasts and monsters in mordor we've done
a lot with the
wildlife as well i'm going to grab a
growl so i can ride it i love it the
machine tribe they're industrializing
motor you'll see more smokes
there's a lot that's cool that's
fantastic
so right now so right now you're
assembling an assault force to go and
just wreak havoc
that's right
he loved 23 yes oh god wow that guy's
awesome
it's fun every single time we show this
game even if it's been all week we have
no idea what's going to happen that's
really exciting and by the way that's
got to be one of the most fun things for
you as a developer is because developers
would play the game over and over and
over but you've managed to create a game
that's different yep every time so you
guys it's it's like playing for the
first time that's amazing and the other
thing that's funny even if you fail oh
hang on i'm gonna let you know like i
did over and over and over yes
[Music]
let's turn this up so you can hear this
bad boy
[Music]
i love this
this is me trying to get my friends to
go out on a friday
oh this is great
what is this that's great
sports
oh a different world
hey sammy99 good to see you
[Applause]
i love it so before we go in i'm just
gonna go i've got my big siege piece
here oh that's great i'm gonna go uh see
like oh hang on there's my wall ground
so he's bashing on the walls over here
i love it and and somebody's asking um
tell the river 85 is asking did you
mocap these characters or did they did
you animate oh it's a combination oh my
gosh oh my god it's already bleeding oh
no catastrophe
so we have our own mocap team and our
animation team's amazing so one of our
lead animators in fact
did not only direct the animation and
does a lot of the hand animation but
also directs the animation and actually
does a lot of the combat moves himself
wow awesome my god all right stop that
uh is the batman arkham style fighting
telling me yes there's an amazing
fighting uh
there's amazing fighting style in this
game it's incredible it's a lot of old
you could parry and i love like i asked
michael i was like how do you block he's
like there's no blocking dude you just
you get he's only counting he's got
little maggots
oh he definitely needs to see a doctor
that's not that's not good okay so i'm
gonna hop off this monster here yeah i'm
going to leave him to fight there and
i'm going to race back
and try and save my followers because
they're bleeding out yeah they're not
they need you
but the thing we've done with the batman
combat system because we have these epic
scale uh battles yeah it was really
important to give you more power to sort
of take on these masses oh no don't play
i don't know
i got it yeah nice he's happy um is
asking how do the enemies get their
levels to start yep so it depends on
where you are in the world so some bits
of mordor are more dangerous than others
others if you go just like hollywood
just like hollywood man if you are deep
into gorgarov the most dangerous places
in the game they're going to be higher
level and tough right but then they get
them from going on missions from
training from killing each other oh the
dwarf height
oh my god oh oh my god oh i love this
guy
thanks man
now i get this loot as well he's got a
great necklace and he beats people in
the face mercilessly yeah i love it and
uh we got all the new loot system now so
because he managed to kill
that other oh i've now got this level 27
rare we can see the gold on it so we can
customize i love player we've got all of
these by the way people are saying
multiple people are saying how smooth
the animation looks and how great it
looks
so there you go it's a high top of it
it's amazing yep um
animation team and our tech team it's
all our own engine so the fact that this
thing performs like smoothly even when
we've just got insanity
our engine team are just amazing yes
that's awesome
okay he's holding it now we're gonna try
this blue circle fell out
now this is ours yeah
so keller brimble is going to plant that
spear uh now we can head into the next
victory point
and that's going to be guarded by more
of these warchiefs so i'll grab some
arrows on the way in fantastic
i wish i could just parkour up a
building like that oh it's like oh man
you can see oh wow holy moly and there's
like just tons of opportunities for
combat so there's bait there's
explosions there's just so you can
really decide you can you oh my god are
those good lord uh you can really uh
attack you can take a fortress several
different ways oh there's nothing
there's not just one way yeah there's
oh no here's another sorry it's my guys
i
people are asking who has the best
goatee i think michael's got the best
goatee oh
oh no
crack one word
that was his word confrontation it was a
good word
hey man you got some oogle you got
something uh i'm your mirror dude i'm
your mirror you got something right here
that's great the animation is
unbelievable uh facialized facial
capture and it's it's unbelievable
because not only do we have these
thousands and thousands and thousands of
animations they have to fit all these
different cases absolutely and oh he's
retreating okay um people are asking um
let's see here
uh
oh are there micro transactions i don't
know in this game are there micro
transactions um we haven't uh talked
about oh oh my god
oh scratch one machine trickster oh hang
on i did get some gear
oh [ __ ]
and are there other weapons besides
swords that we can use yeah so there's
this area that you could use oh yeah
there's the dagger there's also the
hammer sorry i just got to uh revive
this guy i really like him because he's
awesome and if i let him die and bleed
out there's a chance that if he does
survive he's going to hate me forever
the ability to
have grudges in this game i love yeah
it's all about just building these
stories and these relationships like
these enemies that you love to hate
allies that you kind of hate to love
because they're just sort of horrible
steve994 is asking how did you come up
with the different enemies names you
must have just come up with thousands
and thousands and thousands of different
permutations
for it to create to choose from yeah and
so we just get together you know with
the team uh we think about what's a cool
feature what's a cool sort of um
personality quirk what's in the tribe
absolutely there's there's just
basically the fun thing about this game
is we if we have a cool idea and a fun
name for a villain yeah we've got a
framework where we can stick it in like
there's no limit right we have you know
a thousand good ideas we can stick a
thousand different characters in because
we can uh support that i love
quite proud of it yeah
all right
usually we've got people demoing that uh
a lot more skillful than me so that's
right here you want me to take i can try
to take over here if you want all right
so this
uh it's about to get tough all right
here we go oh it's about to get tough i
love you handsome thing over here all
right here we go so in here so we've
defeated all the warchiefs all right we
fought this battle and now the overlord
is inside oh great
great so when it comes to confronting
the overlord let's give it to all the
players
oh this is gonna be a mess all right
let's do it two things to keep in mind
that are really handy okay on the d-pad
sorry if you just hop down in front oh
sorry
i just love you know no big deal i just
left climbing up stuff and rb to enter
in
the d-pad if you go left you're going to
bring in a monster a carry
okay if you go right you can bring in a
bodyguard all right okay he's good for
you we didn't get in i'm very nervous on
this guy i've got no idea
this looks like a terrible restaurant
there's no tables in here
even my god i'm actually kind of nervous
this is you've done an amazing job at
creating in like an epic environment
it's incredible
oh
there we go
and you have a dumb looking cat lizard
thing
oh my god oh here we go okay so you can
bring in your own dumb looking cat
lizard with one
oh do i have a special why am i freezing
these guys yeah so the hammer killer
brim ball's hammer yeah b button uh you
can freeze them and that lets you flurry
so you can and that builds up your hit
counter and then if you hit
the combos you can now
do
as well got it the traps hurt them too
right yes oh my god
he heard what you said about him yeah
you still look stupid i don't care how
many times you hit me uh y plus b and
you can do a
oh there we go
oh oh oh
did a lot of damage joy man
oh so the left trigger
that's your range so you can um shoot
him in the face which is sometimes handy
in these situations as well oh can't
climb up that
[Music]
you've got three last chances if he does
get you down
that's one oh no just wait for the the
button and
a little early oh no oh i did it oh no i
got oh no i'm sorry i called you stupid
i'm sorry look i'm i'm i'm really sorry
about that
oh carragher
dang it so your nemesis
someone's asking why the orcs look like
his mother-in-law and i'm guessing that
you probably modeled after only he could
answer that exactly yes only he can
answer that so the thing is normally
like video games you fail a mission you
go back and you try and do the same
thing again and we have story missions
like that but
here time's going to move forward you're
a wreath so you're going to resurrect
because of the power of the ring
and now you can try and take that
fortress again the war chiefs you've
killed are still going to be dead
so it's going to be much much easier
yeah your followers that have survived
you're going to be more powerful so
you're still going to make progress
towards
this fortress i love it uh michael thank
you we're going to keep playing we're
going to switch out
guys keep your questions coming i'm
going to keep trying to
kill that son of a
that dumb cat
you're mine cat
hey how's it going ashley good to see
you say hi to everybody on the old
camera there hi
ashley uh look have you played any
shadow of mordor i have no have you
played okay this is shadow of war the
sequel
basically takes place right after the
hobbit
and right before lord of the rings okay
do you want to play
obviously okay great sorry the
controller's really sweaty i might have
a glandular problem uh okay so here's
how you play uh left stick moves around
uh this is gonna run this is your attack
you tap to uh a little attack and hold
it down for a heavy attack okay uh and
then everyone i wanted to know that like
you all should know this is called
clueless gamer yes
we're both clueless still my top is
really cute so it's whatever you know
you have a great cute what about my top
it's cute it's beautiful what kind of
magic wow that was
the fakest cute
it's from old navy okay listen all right
here we go okay so turn around and x
these guys
you're going to turn around yeah xxx
yeah yeah there you go x amount there
you go nice and then you can hit a to
jump over there
oh god
wait
that's all right you're doing good
you're doing good just keep hitting x
all i do is hit a and x there see look
at this
you're a natural
ah now ashley you're on are you on the
flash yeah that's the top yeah the top
now the tops the top i'm going to talk
to you while you play games are you
ready
what are your [ __ ] your superpowers are
to spin around really fast uh no huh
sorry that's in the comics
it's okay
what is it in the uh
oh wow that was amazing how did you do
that
the important part is that in the flash
um
uh so that in the flash my character in
the in the comics is a uh is a guy yes
and so we got to do some gender bending
stuff and um in that i also believe he
has a crazy like green and purple
costume or something but that doesn't
look good on camera so he changed it
perfect but he um so anyway so in my
version of it uh it's still the same
idea where like she actually can control
people's uh minds and their perception
oh i love i wish i had that power right
you know honestly like it's kind of cool
because my super like my super power is
that
in her reality
once she was incarnated as a superhero
after like the explosion then she never
has hit anyone she's never had to be
physical with her powers not once so she
just looks at people induces vertigo and
they get dizzy
and
dizzy's an understatement of the country
and why won't that guy go away no
good here
i'll just this is like a bad tinder date
definitely with the spiders i've had
some bad ones yeah well the fighters is
like the group text like into reality
yeah but anyway so yeah so the flash
it's fun like i guess it'd be like this
like very uh
nice
badass you are you know what i think we
should do i want to bring back the cape
i'm going to start wearing more capes
man
oh my god look at this oh god this is
like a half cake you've got to keep the
sleeves on you're already winning the
game this is great all right all right
let's go this way we're going to go down
to where that uh that yellow diamond is
am i gonna die yeah i wouldn't go down
that way let's go over that i say we go
over there and kind of get down
down yeah don't do exactly what i say
because i'm real dumb
are you really so it balances out i am
i'm like oh my god i'm a genius dude
that's crazy wait a minute
wait you're like so do you see the world
like uh bradley cooper limitless like do
you just like see everything i don't
know the way i see it or not probably
not because all i see is like a great
great blobs floating through the world
wait so you took immense you took a
mental test you took a i should talk to
people that can't help
but yeah no i took the test you had to
take it from like a real psychologist
and then go in and just bananas and then
it surprised everyone
um i wasn't surprised
i always knew you were a genius actually
i know wait let's talk about that why is
the ground farting i'm not sure it looks
very princess bride asked i wouldn't
it's like a meta music emotion
i normally in games and in life don't go
towards things that are erupting out of
the ground actually whole day you can
run if you hold that oh yeah there you
go there you go yeah
no wait you uh
when you were on the show um
awkward
you got to direct an episode i got
direct too
and what did you learn by directing um i
learned is that your first time
directing is it okay if i say uh
i'm gonna just go with naughty words can
i swear i'm here oh no no
well my mother's watching your mother's
wife so maybe not sorry mom
fair enough get your dad where am i
going i said go this way go this way
go that way just jump down let's see
what happens
859 feet or 850 feet yeah are you sure
i'm yeah i think i die after that battle
you know what i'll take the blame
michael get mad at me
go for it just just run bayman will get
mad at you no michael the the the
creative uh the creative head of this
game direction wait something's
happening hello el gringo
you guys got questions for uh ashley
rickard yeah get him in questions also
too how are you what's up
how's your friday how's your friday bro
oh somebody call it a ground fart yes it
was a ground floor it's a ground park
scene my god you're running super fast
oh god what's up what do i do with that
that thing seems like a thing oh that's
somebody just left their skin and bones
where do i go
you guys should i start a twitch account
people are saying they love the music's
joke
great use of next check she's in
medicine dude she's super smart wait it
wasn't wasteful it was metamucil music
oh yeah good patrick riker you screwed
up
patrick i appreciate the sun that's
right
oh people love the flash
oh yes you should no no wait yes no yes
you should oh no oh no oh no
dude kill him oh oh no i got you i got
you yep i got you oh yeah x amount x
amount x amount
boom
oh we got you yep
the best thing about
uh one of the great things about uh
shadow of mordor and shadow of war is
you can take people over
so if you ever get oh my god oh goodness
oh dude you are stone cold literally
oh my god what is even happening
critical hit
again i want to ask the audience should
i get a twitch account i think the
answer is yes and can you also guys
start following me on social media oh
yeah what are your now what are your
handles ashley ricard's my name ashley
rick very easy absolutely no then it
gets actually gets complicated what's
that thing do i fulfill that dr
manhattan says yes starting choice okay
oh my god
mixer oh no people are saying don't got
nightmare joker saying don't go to the
purple platform
what they said
so we have we're streaming on a lot of
platforms okay cool and the platforms
are just having a fight between them
i'll go on whatever exactly you know
what if you go on all platforms then all
platforms
that's right
they won't have to fight over you
because you'll be on all the platforms
don't fight guys
but yes everybody wants you to start a
twitch account okay so i'm including
your boy aaron blair that's me i love
you love you too but uh okay
um
my mom is a therapist that's why i'm so
messed up
you said it
yo i did say it this is where i started
exactly jump off just do it
oh you got to go for it
you got to go i don't have any money on
me but i would give you money if you
jumped up
jenna has my wallet is there any is
there any money in there there's
probably not oh we good we good
or just have a good hang i'm not sure
what that meant what got you know like
there's a hang thing if you go to the
corn the side it says you can press p
i can press one hang you can press b and
hang if you go to the side you can hang
off
see b hang uh
nice
see look that wasn't that bad
that was fine that wasn't that bad
um
yes so ashley records and then it's
power b at the end of that for instagram
power b yeah like okay so to be honest
guys wait the word power and then b
so
oh no the whole story is that i thought
it was i thought i was saying power
[ __ ] i thought i was saying that and
then what i actually was saying
was um
i was saying uh power bottom which i
wait is that true it apparently is what
it reads like oh my brother
i i don't have a problem with the bottom
like you do you
we all got our our places and our
preferences but like this guy
you're kicking the crap the crap
have you ever heard the donald glover
thing of he
donald glover just looks like dong lover
um todd glover did i get it on social
media dog lover
i think you killed it okay but you're
also on fire so i would get out of there
i'd say i see one of them
i think you want to run the other way i
think you want to you want to run
towards that thing
towards what how cool is this by the way
have you ever been to a climbing gym
yeah i love rock oh man i've never done
it
how do you is it hard to
i don't know if my fingers are toughness
strong enough these little babies you
know
yeah
i love it
um okay where do i go
run towards the rent towards the diamond
who kill those dudes kill those dudes
this is great
oh yeah oh oh man oh man this is awesome
but there's someone else behind me i can
feel them that's right
and we all know it's power [ __ ] we
know what it is yeah and then um
and then twitter is my name that's my
name that's easy easy-peasy
i think you should do it i'm going to my
other platform accounts too are you now
uh did you go to e3
oh yeah i did and what games did you
play the elections um i played uh well i
just finished playing
the uh
oh no no no no no no no
i gotta get on the other side
you're a master of somersaults for sure
do you play games in your free time
this is my first time playing this game
i don't really play video games really
but i love you dude you're killing
everybody this is nice
of just playing video games and it's
been that's right
that's right
uh yeah brandon i think you can heal
yourself we don't know how but yes you
can oh no no why why oh
oh
ashley crook
oh my god
all right well
well i mean you did kill a lot of dudes
so i think it's like i think it's like
30 to 1. you're ahead you're right good
that was one that's your records
everybody yes you should start a twitch
everybody thinks you should everybody
thinks you should everybody thank you
very much
all right now we gotta we gotta get some
revenge for ashley that was ridiculous
spear in the chest what are we doing
come on in come on in how are you good
good introduce yourself to everybody hi
i'm harvey sheena and i'm your friend so
nothing's talking about
that's right she told she told me you're
gonna be here yeah i was emailing her
like are you gonna be here she like no
yeah she doesn't do stuff now she's not
where are you yeah don't be cool
certainly called out
uh
we are playing shadow of war great it's
awesome did you play shadow of mordor no
okay
a lot of lego games oh okay video games
are great i love them i'm like the games
are great i'm like that like this is a
little more intense than a lego game i'm
just going to warn you just straight up
i'm going to warn you a little bit
um guys we're just joining us we are uh
at the uh team coco plus xbox live
gaming event here at the
microsoft
lounge in venice
and we're going to be playing forza 7 a
little bit later as well as crackdown 3
right now we're playing shadow of war
which is incredible it's the first time
it's been extreme uh it comes out
october 10th
and uh it picks up right where shadow of
murder are left off and basically the
idea is yeah so between that you saw a
lord of the rings movies right okay
great between the hobbits and the first
lord of the ranks for 60 years right
okay it's a long time well i've always
been told i look like gimli son of boy
i mean i i guess if you had like a
helmet my hairline goes up there like a
helmet and then like braids and then the
giant axe it's mainly when my friend is
mad at me he calls me gimli son of gloin
and then we sing it like a britney
spears oh my god gimli son of glory son
of boyd dimly givingly son of glory
that's great and that it works go
towards the diamond go towards the
diamond the yellow diamond we got to get
revenge for ashley okay so i can go down
there i'm going to die
just do it you got to live a little oh
wow oh look at that yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh there's major hangings hanging fruits
though you know when you see a cliff you
don't just
die i know so basically what happens is
this so the end of the hobbit sharon
wakes up right yeah
and uh
so what happens is we uh have forged and
a shadow of mordor we forged a new ring
of power which we have now and that's
why we have these powers because uh i
want to say i'm going to get it wrong
i'm going to get it wrong uh killer
killer briber
uh is the elf who's who's uh made the
rings and he his spirit is intertwined
with ours so that's why we have the
power of the ring rings and watch this
are you following any of this yes kind
of but like awesome so basically here's
the deal so now uh we need to go we need
to uh get an army together you'll fight
sauron so in this city really starting
at like the village oh yeah man exactly
we gotta get we gotta get peace you know
we can't just go up against sauron bear
fisted that's these combos are awesome
yeah dude it's got the same um fighting
system as backup batman arkham knight
just different fun
i remember playing that with the kids i
used to babysit oh my god you feel like
a superhero and in this you feel like an
epic fantasy hero because you're just
destroying everyone um so you can take
guys over uh you can uh and all the
enemies are dynamic so they're all brand
new they're generated every time you
play the game go kill that dude that
dude wants to be murdered up there you
can see it you can just see it how can i
ride it uh hey
and also a oh my god that's really fast
a will also like have you jump over them
oh dude i think my boyfriend is really
proud of me yes again i normally play as
well he should be because you're look at
this you just need that dude in the face
well i normally play like i'm such a
child i play like a lot of hearthstone
right now hearthstone's great
hearthstone's amazing no idea and then
like my best i didn't even know this my
best friend danny pooty who should be
here but he's got children and he's in
chicago daddy pooty's
like literally i saw dan harmon here and
i'm just waiting to tell him like yes
foodie should be here but foodie did a
bunch of commercials for hearthstone and
i'm like i've just turned into this
gamer emphasis on the why in game
is that me really yeah i'm a gamer
[Laughter]
also yeah so that's your power move when
you can either hit these two or these
two i wouldn't do it now but when
there's a lot of guys around you
let's go attack the thing run towards
the uh the yellow diamond run towards
the yellow diamond all right playing the
wrong way so basically so after the
hobbit and before the first floor of the
rings uh uh book or movie fellowship of
the ring this is what happens and you
are behind enemy lines and causing all
this havoc so sauron can't get his uh
eventually like will we get the elves
will we get everybody that's a great
question i don't know
i don't know i hope so
that's
right find a life 2016. it's coming soon
the next serious chat is happening hey
guys
awesome if i can do it
you can do it
wang there is a finishing strike this is
true this is true
uh how's your day
as we just go around it is great this is
great uh this is fantastic we're here uh
at the microsoft lounge in venice uh at
the super have you come to these parties
before you know what this is my first
time because my best friend stone shaw
from scrubs go on her boyfriend jacob
get in there get in there
emmy a nominee for powerpuff girls which
she's a voiceover oh my gosh
jacob's sister rachel is one of the
coordinators of the microsoft live they
were just having a great time thank you
rachel thank you jacob thank you so much
i love it letting me be this nerd and
gamer and show my boyfriend that yes i
can play more than legos
so you're gonna oh no oh no no wait
you're not dead yet there's going to be
a button oh no you're going to see soon
oh
oh gosh oh that's
oh that's brutal
oh that's beautiful
also that guy doesn't need armor he's a
giant thank you tarzan's cars just
really destroyed it this is excellent
yes this is super fun we saw this out
there have you now what are uh have you
played any games here that you've liked
sea of thieves sea of thieves yeah very
fun exactly a pirate game pirate game
is all new to me too because
fantastic so this is this is the
fortress that we're going to go attack
and we can choose people to be on our
side the blue or we could go against we
can mark these bad guys i've marked the
head of the castle out there because he
killed us once and i wanted to destroy
him right so i say hit b let's go back
hit b let's get back in the fight
taurus now becomes stronger exactly
when they kill you they become stronger
because all their friends were like hey
you killed that dude
i love it
all right really enjoying the street
people are loving you
bless them thank you guys what are your
social handles where can people follow
parvati on twitter and like an idiot i
lost my ed parvez instagram oh
i know dude oh
oh this isn't going to be good
you hey his last name's giggles i know
he can't be all that bad hello giggles i
think you're gonna have to kill giggles
there we go get him get him oh no nope
not gonna work
oh gosh
oh nice hey all of a sudden you're like
amazing at this game no but he gave he
he's got that like chokehold oh good
lord oh
roll out of trouble that's what i do
just roll out of trouble
oh goodness
oh thank you steal all his minions oh no
oh that's going to definitely leave a
mark
that's not you're not going to want to
get your prom photo taken after that
you're going to want to wait a few weeks
for it until you see my freshman year
yep homecoming so there's no blocking
but there is you can parry so when
they're red i think yeah you want to
jump out of trouble or if there's yellow
you want to hit y to jump out of trouble
there
i feel like it's a better strategy
should i be killing all the minions
first yes absolutely
why are you not killing the minions
right
oh my gosh there's a lot of pressure and
i've had a cocktail
or four that's right they do have
special xbox one one x
oh yes you did it you did it that was
great
all right now i get it that was great
that was great
that's amazing
no
i'm too close oh my god all right guys
in about 10 minutes we're going to play
four to seven so pervasive is gonna bam
oh
no no no get out wait don't wait don't
hit the button hit the x x x yes dude
you're great at this now you're getting
it take that giggles
if that is your real name oh my god that
was an amazing move that was like a
swing dance move
yeah okay
we have a lot of choreography on green
just like again exactly yeah i am
learning exactly thank you kat burns
your emmy is well deserved
oh i'm so every time
it comes out in slow motion i just want
to curl up and exactly because you know
it because you know it's coming
it's very it's basically like a wonder
woman movie move like yeah i know i'm
gonna something's gonna happen exactly
wait when does crazy ex-girlfriend air
when does it air um we're gonna be
october 13th i believe is uh
we're gonna be back with jane the virgin
on cw are you guys filming now we start
july 10th
that's exciting oh it's the best or are
you nervous to go back to work i'm very
nervous because i think i might be
singing this season
well i feel like you have probably have
a pretty good singing voice
yes
that was a high e i think you guys i
didn't warm up
it's very loud in here there's a lot of
music playing it's hard to tell there's
a lot of trip hop in the background
exactly exactly i normally listen to
classical when i play my video games
exactly my boyfriend calls it picture
game
wesley west thinks this is pre-recorded
all right wesley west
bye
bye
why would it be
recorded he's hitting me with a hat yes
why would we pre-record this oh my god
that was
awesome there's no conspiracy theories
oh my god privilege thank you so much
thank you my pleasure that was amazing
oh my god soda
i can't believe you didn't come sona
very upsetting very upset i just got to
show the shirt yes
oh i love it i love it thank you thank
you thank you see you later
you your venue giggles
it's a great name now again guys all
these enemies and shadow of war are
dynamically created so you're going to
get people like azran's dwarf that just
happens thank you for that it's amazing
um all right i'm going to play a little
bit and then we're going to switch to
forza 7.
again get your questions in we have a
lot of developers here we'll be talking
to you today
tonight i should say
uh and if you're on the east coast thank
you for staying up with us
once again this is the team coco
plus xbox gaming event live from
microsoft lounge in venice california
it's so beautiful down here guys it's
amazing um hey can we get a shot
o'malley of the rest of the party
o'malley creeper in the corner this is
what this is what happened there you go
there you go
people all playing a bunch of stuff hey
what's going on man
rob hey rob good to see you what's
happening uh i think do you want to play
some shadow of war or should we play
forza shut up all right place it all
right here we go now look this guy
we gotta kill this dude man we've just
been murdered time after time after time
we're gonna go after him all right
because have you played any shadow of
war and not for about a year or two okay
well it's new so by the way that you're
like your first round why don't you
fight the guy at the top of the castle
he's always the easiest go big or go
home that's what i say and normally i
actually go home so all right let's just
run towards the uh the yellow a little
diamond there what is uh what's run run
is a run is a there you go yep
there's no wrong answer
all right there you go uh so x is going
to be attack
and y is kind of like a parry situation
uh oh yeah oh you can x that dude rod
just run up to him
how's it going
it's
there you go oh yeah oh yeah oh this is
great and you can also hit a and you'll
like roll around and stuff oh critical
hit look at this look at this oh wait
isn't there a counter button there there
is it's y is the counter block
yes
oh my god you're a natural now
do you know are you uh in real life do
you get into a lot of sword fights
because you seem like a natural honestly
i've been more of a pacifist lately
lately though lately nunchuck fights on
the regular here's the thing about
nunchucks now i don't mean to take an
oppositional view here but
i feel like you're about to i would hit
myself in the face many times
you know i feel when i was a kid playing
t-ball i hit myself in the face with a
bat now that wasn't
uh two bats connected by a chain there
was just one bat i hit myself so like a
thing on a chain i feel like i would
just constantly smack myself in the face
right i got well yes if the short answer
is yes okay fair enough uh run towards
the yellow thing so you go back that way
if we were about to go into combat you
and i i wouldn't say hey you're out of
the gate you should probably start with
some nunchucks right
well you brought the nunchucks up i
thought you were a nunchuck master
michelangelo uh teenage ninja turtles
you know the guy could block all sorts
of stuff with his nunchucks amazing
amazing i'm not sure what this is oh
it's unfinished business yeah yup
yup we're taking oh who's this dude i
don't even have an animal that guy's got
you know we can call an animal though
don't worry we can michael yeah the
creative director of the game came and
he showed me how to call an animal so
you don't worry about the animal calling
we're going to get that i'll say where
can people follow you on social media
let's see uh on twitter on robert
buckley on instagram i think i'm robert
earl buckley robert i don't really
really feel like
that day i'm gonna put all the names in
there game on friend
uh oh shoot wait do you want me to fight
this guy or should i just keep running
towards i mean i like what you're doing
here a lot of postering i'm gonna
you know um that's good i think you're
just telling him you're coming for him
basically
you're warning him get ready oh no
you're actually coming for him okay cool
yeah we're going for it let's go for it
i wanted i know we don't have a lot of
time so
yeah i want to get it real hot
why is he not letting me run
because i think he has to say a bunch of
crap to you
villains villains always need exposition
don't they
like we don't get out of here
that's what makes a good feeling
fire caller that is uh a face for radio
people are saying the bat story explains
a lot thanks a lot guys yeah oh guys
come on
good lord
wait is izombie feeling not filming now
or no we start filming again in august
are you nervous about going back to
school basically or no you kind of how
long have you been off for uh it's been
four months wow that's crazy what have
you been up to in the last four months
besides getting into random sword fights
on the street like i said a lot of
nunchuck fights a lot of nunchuck fights
so many took fights that's east l.a for
you i feel like
yep you're gonna grab a bunch of arrows
go to yo god no you're gonna want a lot
of x a lot hitting a lot of a
running is good too yeah i'm just gonna
you know i'm saying ashley uh richards
was over here earlier we're saying that
we should bring the kate back wow that
seemed unnecessary
that was a little like can i ride that
guy no needs a bad cat but you know what
let's press this button i'm gonna press
this button and call it press the left
d-pad
oh god
oh boy
having a field day with me that field
day
karagor killed us that's okay carragher
killed me many times don't feel bad
again to the untrained guy i think you
may have picked the hardest single
battle for us in this demo untrained i
would be very trained i did pick the
hardest guy let's pick a different guy
yeah how about i pick are you how about
i pick this guy that guy audrey
first of all
pretentious trickster
trickster and there's nothing regal
about this guy i agree you know what
he gets marked for death perfect i love
this this is fantastic
wait okay
now we how do we go to battle now uh b
hit the b
i really want to i really want to leave
with a win under my belt i think you can
do it everyone else is left with a loss
you will be the first winner by the way
really of the night here's my thing i
i'm a bit
of an archer
okay
you're gonna watch i think left trigger
kind of throws
i don't know what oh electron i think
trigger yeah yeah that throws like
throwing things okay throwing blades
and then i think right so you can do
that
i think if you hold left trigger then
maybe hit right trigger i think you can
there you go that's what it is this is
your thing man we're in it now and now
these guys are in trouble that's right
field day
oh read by nature great joke italian
don't accept any other kind of cargo
child that's an extremely nerdy and
fantastic show well done
oh got a lot of yeah exactly a lot of
izombie fans in the chat
vfx ninja editor that's right
merciless
yeah buddy
oh boy
death count five yes that's true but you
know what this is going to be the last
this i believe there's not
i'm not going to die he's going to he's
going to destroy ogg the regal is that
who it was absolutely
i kind of feel like these are mine to
take yeah yes absolutely man i think
they also never quite come out of the
wall they're just kind of perma arrows
oh boy so they're also like great
decoration whoa good run they would make
a nice lamp they have a sweet
glow all right
yeah
after uh rob either dies or defeats
ogder eagle we're going to play forza 7.
i i feel like no pressure enthusiasm in
the way no fresh a lot of confidence no
pressure no you know what there was it's
a challenge to you it's a challenge i
just you know i don't want to i don't
want to take it easy on you
i'm over here fighting my butt off all
this dude
so dead
oh and he kicked somebody off the wow
instant karma look at how blood is
that's right
don't kick someone off the ledge or you
friend it might be kicked next
that's some pretty good parkour there
goes parkour i apologize to your viewers
because i appear to have picked the
villain who is the furthest away from
everything in the game in outer earth
not in middle earth he picks a guy
i mean that's right oh boy find a life
we're at the microsoft lounge in venice
partying it up and there's actually a
drink tonight that is like the xbox one
x drink i heard what yeah that's true
i'm not sure i think i'm not actually
sure what's in it i think cucumbers or
something i don't know because they're
green i have no idea
this is a ball i just hope i just hope
it doesn't taste like an xbox
you know like that's what would you let
me ask you guys what would an xbox taste
like a burnt plastic
what is the orange skull is someone else
died here uh that's a dude i think you
can use murder
i think he's uh oh
oh no i think maybe that's something you
can get a dead guy
i got to run around this mountain here
oh is that what it is it's a giant you
can't climb up it huh no because you
climbed up that wall very easily i i
again i i picked the single worst phone
and i apologize to all the viewers have
you been uh to a climbing gym
i have have you man am i the only pr jim
have you been to a climbing gym all
right good i thought i was the only
person in l.a
you know it's everybody on tv has been
on a cliff i think that's a thing right
can i tell you it's something you should
try okay why go ahead why let's hear it
what's your argument for climbing i'm
all for any new sort of uh adventures
that are humbling and trying to climb
such as fighting ogden regal you're
about to be this isn't going to be
humbling this is going to be a real
chest beating exercise i'm going to
crush this guy i love this i love your
confidence
uh okay so it's humbling i get it and i
feel like these are not very strong
think do i have to have strong fingers
because i have like
noodles you blow out yeah farms in like
30 seconds
i basically have noodles stuck and do
two hamburger patties or my hands
ladies don't get excited unless you're
hungry then you know oh he's not dead oh
no
dude that guy's been eating his wheaties
oh oh goodness oh jeez
you turned very canadian there all of a
sudden i sure did didn't i oh
okay aug has got to be here somewhere
he's you know where he is he's
he's 100 he's that way
100 or so feet
okay you ran really fast because you
were about a mile away
i tried i could feel the viewers getting
bored of my stream that's not true at
all viewers love you uh this guy this
guy's been
this is it here we go here comes a big
show on hey hey look at he's he's
gaining on me is he everybody in the
chat has been to climbing gyms what is
wrong with this am i i'm missing out
perhaps
[Music]
here we go blue blue area
do it
oh my god what's happening what
fork the worm is pursuing on the regal
reward uh start
yeah sure by the way it started we got a
poisonous feral berserker first in a
trickster
which is basically a magician yeah ag is
basically a magician and take it from
the former child magician nothing
intimidating about him were you a child
magician legitimately was wow respect
so do i do i control one of these guys i
think these guys are gonna kind of fight
and then you're gonna get in there and
pick up the pieces so you see he's you
go murder him you're going to help the
blue guy kill them
you know what i'm saying so they're
chasing og you're going to help chase
him down and kill him
oh here we go oh dude oh man
terrible by the way terrible runner yeah
his form is awful oh look out for traps
oh yeah oh beat up just get him
no don't do that oh god oh sorry dudes
oh
oh we'll look at oh no see classic
trickster classic ugg
classic oh that's him that's him he's
wearing black lipstick for some reason
why should i be button smashing okay i'm
really leaning into the button smashing
fun fashion's good you definitely want
to smash that x
oh jealous it's never been no climbing
gym thank you
og the regal no relation to
no i don't think so
wait beth you went to a
a 1920s themed party at a climbing gym
yeah
oh they're retreating you did it you got
your first w oh that was a terrible time
yeah
robert thank you so much thank you for
having me that was amazing and where can
people follow you again social media uh
robert buckley on twitter or robert
robert earl buckley
on instagram on instagram fantastic
thank you robert that was fantastic dude
awesome awesome have fun tonight uh guys
we're gonna switch to forza 7.
if you're just joining us again tonight
we are playing forza 7 crackdown 3. we
just played shadow of war which is
super super fun that comes out october
10th
uh later of course we'll be playing a
little artful escape we're here at the
microsoft lounge in venice and you're
watching the team coco plus
xbox
gaming event um here we go
all right so uh oh here we go i have to
change controllers that's the big thing
guys got to change the old controllers
so this is really exciting forza the new
forza 7 has over 700 cars which is the
most cars of any forza game
uh and also you can we are not streaming
in 4k you can play this bad boy 4k
uh hdr 60 frames a second which is crazy
has the most uh the largest collection
of porsches ferraris and lamborghinis in
the world and uh we got three tracks to
choose from
so we're gonna go with my the first one
uh that i want to play because that has
dine it shows up the dynamic weather the
nissan track here we go and for the
first time you can see the drivers out
of the cars we have male and female
drivers which is extremely exciting of
course
and uh
it's incredibly cool this game is
insanely beautiful and you can check out
all uh 700 cars or over 700 cars and
forza vista which is of course the view
where you can blow up everything about
the car you can blow up the engine you
can look at the pistons the intakes
gaskets head gaskets i don't know
anything about cars a hedge gaskets a
thing in a car
people are videotaping me because i
don't know anything about cars uh but
you can do it all in force of said which
is fan uh unbelievably uh super fun and
um it comes out october third and it was
developed actually with the xbox one x
hardware so as that was developed so is
forza 7 so it's making uh the most use
of any game so far created from the xbox
one x uh so again we're gonna be playing
on the nissan circuit and this has some
dynamic weather
which means it's different every single
time you play and different every single
lap
so uh let's just hope it doesn't get too
uh too gnarly you can obviously uh
i'm gonna put it on easy for the first
lap uh for the first race and then we'll
put it on hard but obviously you can see
the assist here
you can get
everything you can go full manual if you
if your heart so desires or if you're a
masochist like me and you're terrible at
driving games uh but what i'm gonna do
is not veteran not professional not
custom we're gonna go easy baby which
i've been told you just need to hit
gas and go
which is great uh and also there's uh i
believe over 200 pieces of customizable
gear
and one of the things i really love
check this out this is super cool
um
but you can see the smudges on the visor
isn't that amazing
unbelievable
uh
and every single piece of gear this is
going to get super nervous every single
piece of gear uh is a separate 4k asset
so the helmet is a separate 4k asset the
suit the gloves which means you can see
the stitching uh they can get incredibly
granular with everything i think this
looks good right here
this looks pretty great right black gold
black gold
um so yeah let's get into it
michael mohler oh
mueller i think mueller
all this
get on in here man aaron good to see you
take a seat all right gonna play a
little forward to here you're gonna play
this you're gonna you're gonna play this
one
so uh this is forza 7. have you played
this at all i have not all right this is
gonna be great let's let's see that i
played it for ten seconds so i'm no
better than you
um it's on easy so don't worry so it's
already easy so i feel like here's what
we'll do
we're gonna we're gonna we'll do this
track we'll see what your time is that
i'll try to beat it what do you think
about that all right yeah
let's do it hit a hit
so
all i need to know is accelerate brakes
reverse accelerate is triggered brake
okay this uh is uh left trigger um and
why uh rewinds time if you so need it
and if you want to switch your uh your
view you can hit the old uh whatever
this button is the option button
robin is racing dude roman is racing
the last time i was racing i was
actually
on her track
is that true yeah oh my god well tell us
the story my brother and i we were
with the
lamborghini team racing their new
huracan oh my god what yeah wait what so
what what kind of lamborghini did you
drive the new lamborghini which
that's crazy it's a fantastic car it's
actually
surprisingly um is it faster than my
2009 jeep wrangler i'm not sure i don't
think because that thing can move that
thing by the way the license plate jock
jams that's my license my lap time is
being destroyed right now it's not
terrible
this is embarrassing
yeah dude so wait if i rewind does that
mean i get the startup well yeah you can
rewind a bit i mean like correct your
last mistake
do i have a handbrake that's what i need
you do uh try x
that's the e-brake
that's how you do you do that you do one
of these what you got you drink were you
nervous driving a lamborghini that you
were gonna
scratch it or oh absolutely not they had
insurance i said hey wow only driving
this if you guys are serious that's how
fast did you get up to
i can't say 32 miles an hour 32 miles no
actually i got up to 161 miles like
yeah
it was ridiculous
oh my god man that's crazy that car
handled well wow did it feel like you
were going fast or didn't feel like it
was just gliding um because i feel like
you know a lot of those
you know super expensive cars they just
it's just like so smooth you don't even
know you're going that far here's the
thing you know that you're going fast
you feel the intensity of it but you
don't feel the
um
you don't feel
the car start to shake up you know i
mean past 100 miles per hour right
it's made to accelerate it's made to go
faster right you have to push it so the
faster you go the better it performs wow
and i was just like
am i going to die doing this
we'll see what way to go what a way to
go yeah it was fun though that's awesome
you're low you're super low right bro
you feel like you're in a kit car like
wow
total
i don't know man you haven't seen me
play yet i'm the worst
i
i remember back in the day my game of
choice on the track was
i think it was need for speed
need for speed yeah that's awesome
i got to play we did a um so i work for
conan we do a clueless gamer segment
where code and i play games and we got
to play in dallas stadium in ttt stadium
on the three
story high screen that played deep for
speed and it was four three stories man
on that giant jumbotron that it was
insane i mean just the noise coming out
of those speakers was unbelievable it
was absolutely incredible
but that was like my house what's that
yeah i mean i would need a three-story
house or you put in your backyard you
can put your backyard yeah yeah what's
the big deal man you know like the
neighbors you know it's fun
just i feel like plant some high trees
to block out the noise and you're all
good you know exactly it doesn't matter
so wait what's my laptop right now
because that's a great question uh
you're at 357.
oh i know that but you're in first place
man versus 24.
if you guys have questions for all of us
get them in yeah what's happening did
you did you get to uh e3 this year
i didn't ah but you came here though so
you got to play some figures yeah i was
like this is my e3 there we go this is
the way to do it man better music than
e3 for sure exactly you know better
drinks too
i was actually on my way to get drinks
they were like play games
exactly
so let me know are you what games do you
are you a gamer at home
i am a gamer at home
primarily i'm in the rpg world titanfall
call of duty oh nice um let me see uh
man
i had to restart
uh what should we call it final fantasy
15. wow wait why'd you have to restart
it because i got to the end of the game
and there's a place where once you get
to a certain level you can't go back and
start you know
assign missions and stuff you can't you
can't do side measures that possible
but when i was there my guys are all at
like 42 44 level the monsters i'm
fighting are like 72. so i was like all
right let me just start all over hit the
side mission yeah yeah build yourself up
a bit yeah
let me see so 4
56
best life is 221 that's
not fantastic but it's all right all
right you ready to see something
terrible watch this 456 eh i bet i'll be
six minutes
wait i mean uh yeah exactly
this is crazy this is also like i was
saying earlier
4k
hdr 60 frames a second this is a crazy
crazy crazy so ridiculous are you a car
guy
he asked the guy who drives lamborghini
do you watch racing do you watch racing
own a lamborghini
i do
but better though because then you have
to take care of it exactly drive other
people's every kitties said no bro i
have a 67 fastback that i'm rebuilding
right now well that's awesome so i'm i'm
very much a car guy did you you did you
grow up against a car guy and all this
stuff like now i grew up as a designer
gravity
graphic designer so i was in the
architecture um my job now is like i'm a
micro mechanical engineer i'm a
watchmaker so i do that
awesome but i got a buddy of mine
but you're a watchmaker yeah yeah that
is the coolest thing i've ever heard in
my life yeah because i'm a watch guy i
love watching oh we can tell i mean i'm
wearing a terrible mall watch now
because you don't know what's going to
happen because i might have to light
this on fire as long as you're wearing
watch it doesn't matter because guys
here's the thing about watches that i
love first of all they're art it's
wearable art thank you absolutely yes
absolutely which is why i'm so impressed
and legitimately like it that's
incredible and also it's like us guys we
can't
express ourselves a lot of times like
ladies we can wear all kinds of stuff
but guys we only get like left right
afterwards yeah you just get like a
watch this is beautiful what's this oh
thank you this is a uh glass
face wow man
one of my favorites i like it it's
simple chill simple and chill it doesn't
try too hard understated elegant this is
we've turned this video game straight
into a watch stream yeah lambo they just
got the best laptop on the never break
is that true yeah oh yeah yeah how did
you get how did you get to do that thing
were you just like
how did you get to do that so
brief history so i when i was like 18 i
was in school for
um architecture and product design but i
was also designing cars
so i've always wanted to design a car i
got a buddy of mine wow actually he he
works at tesla but uh they're designing
a car right now concept cars just fun
but i was at sundance they had
lamborghinis out there for some of the
clients i'm like it's snowing i'm not
getting that
i contacted lamborghini
i contacted the rep and they thought
that i wanted a ride in the car i said
no
like
i'm trying to design something yeah you
know that's awesome
so
we had a cool kind of like kickoff to
the relationship there because they knew
that i was really interested in the
the car the performance aspect
transmission all that yeah um
but then from there you know we just
kept it cool and they were kind enough
to to let me uh test one of these things
out for a little bit and then we took it
out to the track that's and uh yeah we
had a race day man
actually the race day is available to
everybody you can you can sign up for a
race day for a lamborghini i
we shot in uh germany we shot an episode
of conan in germany went on the autobahn
and like i think it was a bmw i8 or
whatever which is fun yeah um and it was
a little frustrating i think because
there's traffic on the autobahn it's
like a track you know like
so we got up to about i think like 120
oh man see i can't talk and do this this
was me man this was realistic oh my god
this is awful
what's that got to 140 yeah but it's
like that's also a job but these
professional drivers
it was nuts they would drive
120 miles and they just go up right
behind the car and then oh my god like
thread a needle and it's like
these guys are absolutely incredible one
four he's pretty good
one foot he's fast man before he's fast
i remember the very first time i did 150
and i thought i was
i was pushing it yeah
that's crazy that wasn't an aston martin
dbs oh my god that's awesome
granted i don't own any of these cars
right but that's two again i think
that's better it's better i test them
i'm lucky enough
yeah the thing i love about design and
engineering is when you're on the design
side an actual manufacturing side it
gives you a different sort of access to
these things of course and
you know
you can have some fun apps without all
the expense what do you think about you
know what's interesting is like with the
advent of electric cars you know you
don't need to worry about you can put
the battery you know you don't need to
it changes up the design possibilities
because
you don't need to have a combustion
engine in the front you know so here's
the thing that i mean we're definitely
looking into we have to think about
because
electric is a huge when it comes to cars
i have a uh like i said i got my gas
guzzler which is my 67
but i also have so thirsty it's so
thirsty it's like literally a a tank a
mouth but
um
i you know i got my prize
i enjoy
old school cars i enjoy a regular engine
you know fuel injection all that yeah
but
i understand electric right i just i'm
not all comfortable yet with the idea
like the self-driving car is not my
thing i enjoy it you like the control
as do i a little too much because i'm
going all over the place here
but uh
it's crazy like a tesla
is gonna be a ferrari off the track
right
automatically from from the start that
the drag
drag that acceleration is crazy and
electric ranging is ridiculous that's
true so
i know you start you start like
really unlocking the possibilities and
it's just it's a it's it's amazing that
those cars are then have to be street
legal because they have to like dumb it
down for people so they don't you know
go 600 miles an hour well i'll tell you
this
you never really get the prototype we
always get the word right right exactly
exactly but you unfortunately i would
say uh on the other hand i'm not all the
way side in yet nice i know you're right
i still get the street legal watches and
cars man i love it dude that's crazy
cars watches and cars now what are you
uh first of all where are you where can
people follow you on social media
so on instagram i'm simply at albus
under [ __ ] underscore hogs perfect and
then on twitter i'm at alva's house
awesome
and what are you working on now that you
could is there anything you're working
on you can tell us about
not that i can tell you
i can tell you about my extracurricular
act there we go there we go i'm still
building my watch brandon you know
looking to launch in about a year and a
half or two oh that's cool do you guys
have a name yet or anything or no
actually the name is about still
timepiece but i'm thinking about you
know changing that up so we'll see we'll
see stay tuned
follow my social media and then you'll
know that i'm actually working on my
partners here her name is automobile
rosales fantastic painter we're both
painters uh we spray
is there anything
painting dude that's crazy and uh we're
working on a collection that we're gonna
debut in september so i got oh you know
what
not too bad dude only two only two
seconds totally second respect thank you
honest thank you so much man yeah man
watches cars are pink and fancy there's
alright everybody come on what are you
doing
guys if you're watching
as i know you are sorry i couldn't i
couldn't pay attention to the comments
because i was deep into a competition
deep deep into a competition get in here
get in there hey man man good to see you
what's going on
uh say hi to the chat to everybody hey
guys
keegan allen here keegan here we go all
right keegan
have you played any forza i have played
forwards i played verizon i've played
four's
all the way up to six recently so i'm
excited but i'm not that great at it you
know what i'm worse than you so don't
worry uh i've only played what you've
seen tonight which is about
three minutes i think no uh uh four
minutes and 58 seconds to be exact
fourth season um is this on the xbox one
x i think we're running we're actually
running off of that thing down there oh
you could open it to me and i would have
been like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's really pretty guys yeah i haven't
seen it yet don't stare directly it's
really crazy it is sorry just like
overblown myself
um anyway so we're gonna play here we're
gonna be able to see what i'm playing
here yes so they can see there you are
with a tiny little box bro that's right
uh so we just did the nissan so let's do
something else do you wanna do trucks
what yes let's do trucks let's mess with
this oh i could tell i had i didn't even
see the truck i played as the porsche
yes uh so i had a little bit of uh oh my
gosh now this is like this is cool
this is steven spielberg that's right
exactly like
way more intense we got some exactly
we're gonna hunt down some campers or
counselor whatever was some teenagers
joyriding or something i think
well now the cool thing about about
forza is that you can now customize your
driver with gear yes this looks like
like this guy looks too cool and you can
play men and women which is great men
and women
look at that i'm gonna i'm gonna be this
guy because he looks like he has like a
little bit more protection for his
flashlight he's about to get in his shoe
right i love they race trucks by the way
yeah that sounds like something i would
like come up with after a night of
drinking just like you know what i
should do
trucks
that's crazy have you had they have um a
special drink here tonight the xbox one
x drink oh no i didn't drink like that
i've just been drinking water that's
smart so have i uh but apparently
somebody told me it's got a cucumber in
it i don't know what's going on oh my
god this is serious dude
good lord whoa whoa i'm about to like
just murk all these guys do you think
when they race in trucks they also have
ham radios they're just talking crap to
each other the entire time
yeah
exactly
oh i'm getting spun out oh no i'm not oh
no hold on here we go i love it yes eat
it fresh man
that's right
uh does this game have any old-school
racers yes i believe there's a bunch of
classic tracks here and it's got over
700 cars which is crazy the most of any
forza game which is amazing it's really
neat that's why i never know is it forza
or forza
i know it's like the game developers
keep saying forza right they keep saying
forza it's like a silent key and it
makes me feel dumb because i'm like oh i
love forza oh yes they're like thank you
forzo is very and i'm like oh you
screwed it up again blair what's your
problem
good lord
have you guys got questions for the king
get him in now guys have any questions
for me if not it's okay we are at the uh
team coco plus xbox live gaming event
from the microsoft lounge in venice
california hi conan it is beautiful yeah
conan is at home watching he's like on
his phone like uh why am i not at that
party
because coney we just talked to
everybody about presidential history
conan is the worst person to be at a
party with because
first of all he's tall so you can't hide
from him so you can see he'll just point
you out it's like the eye of sauron
coming down to be like ah
then second of all he'll just talk your
ear off about either like the beatles or
uh you know some random yeah richard
nixon history which is great look i'm
sorry boss please don't fire me i love
you
i bet he would like kill it in this game
though he would that's true
he actually he's played for it and uh i
think it just rams into the wall over
and over this is great by the way i love
this
now wait i heard
in this game because i have a jeep right
okay 2009 jeep wrangler license plate
jock jams that's a true thing
so every time i get a ticket it says
jock jams on the ticket which makes me
laugh
uh
but but yeah so you can blow it up which
is amazing now all this was just saying
he drove a lamborghini what's the
fastest you've ever driven i've got 198
miles oh my god that's even faster than
all this i almost i almost went up to
200 miles an hour that is meant on
purpose on purpose or were you was it
what was going on hyper illegal was it
like a fast and furious you were
parachuting out of a c-137 or something
oh no we were in a really crazy car my
friend has an insane car with a rocket
on the back it has it's a methane-fueled
car
he has the same car and we had like an
opportunity to try it out oh my god
what's insane is that it was within a
small amount of space that we did it and
we were just wait what what's this were
you like in like midtown manhattan
i mean it's like fifth to six it's just
one block and he's like dude check out
this car it's crazy but it's it's like
it's a voyage steiner bmw and whoa with
a v8 supercharge holy moly i mean i
assume he made this eve like it's modded
himself it's like a specialty company
called boydsteiner wow that made it and
it's just rocket ship that is stupid
crazy and is it the acceleration like
it's insane oh my god does it have like
the straps or something or no i think he
has like yeah because i'm gonna want
more than five-point restraint yeah i'm
gonna want more than this thing dude you
know like but it's pretty crazy i've
gone pretty i've gone pretty fast on my
own um in my car i've done like maybe
like 150
but good god that's so i was on a racing
track when i did it that's good the kids
listen close track close track
yeah and definitely not mid-town
manhattan definitely give me that 100 we
did it we did it and it was like very
much considered a close track there was
nobody around that's great that's great
it was not the road to vegas that's what
a lot of people think yeah come on
greenoa grow up grow up okay road to
vegas grow up first of all fly to vegas
what are you doing because it's never
the drive to vegas it's the drive home
that's depressing same with the flight
only the flight's only an hour so if
you're in l.a soon uh sidebar uh here's
what i'm learning from streaming with
everybody tonight all these celebs i
need to try to a climbing gym and i also
need to
get like drive faster than 30 miles an
hour which when you drive what are you
talking about in the game or in real
life i need to i'm not living keegan i'm
not living life well i need to get out
well okay that's true
you may be going 30 but you can go over
everything you can literally climb a
rock wall and pull all of us out
we get stuck there we go so you can go
30 miles an hour but you can literally
climb vertical wall there we go
so that's pretty sick
meanwhile i hit a pothole and it's like
right
[Music]
it's litigation and now i'm now you're
in a whole law and order episode
special vehicle unit you know svu
that's all like car related crimes
you know pixar that should be your next
movie oh yeah let's get into that get on
that cars 3
svu 100 and almost now 20 miles a giant
giant truck
that was
amazing
so fun hey keegan where can people find
you on social media so i have an
instagram my instagram is k-e-e-o
it's kione
i love that i'm a photographer i'm
coming out with my second book soon yes
first book life love beauty is available
but second book pretty little liars is
ending soon it's the season finale
coming up soon there's two more episodes
very exciting i'm gonna be live tweeting
on that at keegan allen
k-p-a-n-a-l-l-e-n on twitter and i also
have a snapchat which is the name of my
first book life love beauty b
all one word all the links will be in
the chat but check it out i really love
uh team coco you guys are amazing dude
you guys are amazing you guys uh they're
on the warner brothers live with us and
they have the best golf carts oh yeah we
have they're all neon they're amazing
and there's a green one too it's so cool
so we're so oh we just have boring beige
golf carts no but we're such happy
neighbors
each other and it's always fun i i still
am thankful to conan for letting me come
that one day that day that dave pearl
was playing yes and played a private
show yeah
that was great so thank you again conan
that was like a dream come true thank
you sir enjoy the party have one get one
of those crazy weird drinks they're not
gonna grab one right now do it guys
we're gonna uh now we're gonna check out
crackdown three
which would be fantastic and uh again as
forza 7 uh comes out october uh third
i'm sure you're checking out you can
race trucks it's crazy what are we doing
and also you can look at jeep wranglers
which is what i'm the most excited about
before it's a vista special vision where
you can blow everything up it's
fantastic uh oh we're gonna play a
little crackdown three you want to come
in sure yeah
they're gonna switch it so we're gonna
be uh we're gonna be a huge uh and say
hi to everybody in the chat what's up
everybody what's up what's up yeah yeah
this is how we're looking at the chat by
the way it's all this is uh this crazy
surface
it's the future man it's the future um
did you get to e3 this year yes all
three days
oh my god that's you're the only person
so far really who's made it about three
days yeah what was that year in a row
what third year in a row
what did you play this year that you
liked
oh man there was so many games that i
loved uh shadow of war was probably
about time we played that earlier very
very fun dragon ball fighterz whoa they
got a dragon ball fight yeah they got a
dragon ball fighting dude game ah yeah
it's awesome do you have a favorite
dragon ball character i've always loved
trunks
maybe because george says the sword
maybe because trunks is like half human
half sand yeah
like oh he's half academy exactly uh but
my favorite was always frieza frieza's
yeah i gotta say though i think having a
tail in real life would be more annoying
than great because you can't find any
pants that fit you you know that's true
but then see i'm just the who's going to
come out with some tail related designs
right
accommodate let's just sell people
that's true you know what you can make a
lot of money uh aimed at aiming at the
tail market yeah that's true because
guys uh wearing wearing pants for for
people for creatures with tails this one
is just a rip in the pants yeah you know
what you just wanted your tail hanging
out there yeah no that's awful that's
that's that's the worst you got to
target a market yeah you got to just
right you got a corner market you've got
a corner of mine in that market but like
i'm in here exactly yeah you got to get
in i know i love this jacket by the way
thank you thank you um so yeah what else
did you play do you like this year oh
far cry was awesome destiny 2 was great
did you play any far cry primal the one
where you're like a cave man i didn't
play that one because we did that so i
work at cone and we do a uh a segment
called clueless gamer uh which i'm sure
a lot of people know and if you're
watching
of course you know why would you be
watching otherwise but um and so we
played that and with pewdiepie which was
great but it's like the thing about what
i love about far cry is you can create
chaos
right when you go in and you attack
these things you can do it your way and
you've got all different weapons and all
this stuff but if i cry primal it's like
oh i have like ugh stick and rock and it
was like you couldn't but this new far
cry is a return to the old right yeah
yeah it's like a back to basics kind of
thing right gave up very very funny it's
very good though very cool awesome i
gotta check the south park the new south
park games oh my god south park i cannot
believe south park
is continues to innovate and continues
to come up with better and better things
that's great
those guys man and they just keep
getting sharper and sharper because most
tv shows i feel like here you can play
most tv shows when they after they have
a movie then they kind of go downhill
yeah some park had a movie and then it
went straight up so i got a movie like a
decade ago and they're even better it's
crazy all right so let's play we're
going to play a little
correct out oh you know what we got the
wrong thing it's got to be this one so
we got to change controllers guys that's
life guys i'm really sorry about that
that's all that's fine that's fine
so uh so i'm going to pick the black guy
because that's who i am and i already
know that this is the only one so far in
this game hopefully some dlc we gotta
diversify these practices come on guys
what are we doing what are we doing
but they do have like
exactly wait but if you crack down on
diversity that means less diverse
all right so crowd three which is kind
of cool to talk about getting back to
basics yes yes uh they're getting back
to basics with crackdown three uh and
they have uh it's it's it's like a
living comic book it's fantastic they
have their cell shading which i love the
look oh yeah that's that shade i love it
and uh so in this in this kind of a demo
we are going to be playing uh so if you
don't know about crackdown you're a
super powered agent you can throw cars
at people uh what it is is we are going
to be um there's five different
attributes which we're going to be
trying to
level up their strength agility firearms
explosives and vehicles uh and it's
awesome i wish i had the powers of this
guy in the game man yeah because like
when you're on the 405 stuck in traffic
how god
it creates a black hole which by the way
is extremely unsafe
it's terrible you don't want to just be
starting black holes no randomly because
they're gonna willy-nilly everything can
be sucked in yeah that's terrible
exactly i as a human being am like an
emotional black hole yes when my
co-workers are feeling happy i'll come
and just suck all the happiness out of
them and then that makes me happy so
then i think it's fine yeah i as an
alien i'm not an emotional black hole
i've sort of thought it out there now
you guys know secret about me there you
go i'm from the horse at nebula get at
me what's up let's go let's talk about
seeing things i've seen things
life is beautiful
exactly now wait where can people find
you on social media oh god uh i'm at
echo k on twitter yeah yeah yeah
on instagram
um what other weird websites are there
hit me up on friends
i don't exist
what else
yeah
okay i can hit them up okay okay yeah so
you know you can do it have you played
this game yet yes okay great
double jump
it was very cool
yeah by the way great if you're not
watching what do you do with your life
dude what do you do if you're not
watching it or you're probably a doctor
yeah you're probably doing something
you're like i'm too busy to watch tv
shows also doctors doctors doctors
should also watch dude
you know like your interns stitch them
up or whatever hey tell the doctors out
there don't be too good for arrow man
like just come check it out
it's a good show for families depending
on what type of family you are yeah yeah
exactly exactly you have a very mature
eight-year-old yeah a great show for you
how fun is it playing a superhero
it's a dream i mean it's amazing it's
like you know it's what every comic book
nerd
who wants to be an actor dreams yeah
yeah i was that comic book nerd that's
awesome and i'm getting to literally
live out my dream right now so dude i
love it what was the what was the
audition process like for that
uh oh that's why right yeah oh that's
but so you got super powers man that's
alright uh the audition process was i
went in and read with the
casting director a lot of beeping just
pretty easy
guys this is all i have people are lying
to society it's amazing okay
oh somebody just said hi attractive
actor guy hi hey
thank you very much for saying that
uh can you go tell my mom that i'm
attractive please she does not believe
me
she's like you're not
you see wait how do i
oh oh somebody wants to know which
characters are alive going into next
season you can't talk about uh well let
me just say you were all dead as oliver
said it's just him oh so that's it we're
dead as heck um people love your
character and arrow big fans oh thank
you guys also we're getting a lot of
other emotional black holes in the chat
i'm sorry to open that up to people
that's okay guys we need to let's hug
each other let's be nice let's hugs more
rock right wait what am i saying yeah
more hugs more hugs more rocks
and more rocks
oh yeah
dude i'm like
whoa
yeah can you get the agency's cars i
don't know i think we can steal any cars
in this game
we're about to find out oh what's
this in the car
is that what that's what i've been
saying
yeah people want to see you oh what is
that that's bad
all right i'm going to go steal the
cargo you're doing good you're doing
good everybody i'm doing good thank you
exactly
sit down
humble there's a car can i see this car
kendrick oh my god this is oh
i said stop the cars the jams at this
party are great whoever's dj
we got a little tender going on right
now yeah we got some good jams y'all
if you like jams
come on to the xbox team coco
what are you looking to do
so wait if you want to change guns if
you want to get the rocket launcher
there you go i want to steal a car oh
there you go
oh there guys there it is
oh yeah come here give me that car i
like how all future cars by the way the
hubcaps like i have like no hubcap like
what's going on like you know that's how
they know they can go oh that was
aggressive what the that was aggressive
whoever did that
what's
pressed that oh yeah everyone's saying
terry crews
is he in this is he i think he was in
the promos for this game
god man terry crews who's the he's like
a human ray of sunshine oh yeah you want
to talk about the happiest man ever oh
my god we shot a thing with him and it
was like for the rest of the week i was
floating up that was awesome
yeah
oh yeah
that's
so happy so happy it's frightening me
actually a little bit terry crews i love
the weapon up here um
hey guys by the way crackdown 3 comes
out november 7th it's an xbox one x
launch title oh my gosh which is great
comes back comes out on the same day the
xbox one x goes
are you are you a gamer uh uh on your
free time you play games oh yeah heck
yeah oh yeah what are you what are you
playing anything now what are you
playing now
right now let's see tekken this is what
is this gun dude uh i don't know but i
think it's going down
i played that for the first time last
night it got panned by the critics but
it's just a good dumb fun time i agree
it is horrifying man oh would that music
play dude oh my god i'm terrified i'm
like oh my god where's he where's jason
there's something about playing against
other people and having them stalk you
that's like the scariest thing it's
amazing yeah it reminds me a lot of real
life whoa
just kidding guys all the ladies trying
to right yes right
ladies and gentlemen so many got ladies
please ladies please stay away stop stop
playing
all you ladies out there who are really
exactly making it uncomfortable for me
one of the things i love the most about
cracked out three is it's got uh first
of all it doesn't once the action starts
it never stops stops the story unfolds
through this thing they call the free
jack system which is it just updates you
on what's going on throughout the game
so as rival gangs try to bite back and
and kill you and you're killing them
they store it you can just and it's the
game is open as soon as you start so you
can try to go kill the head guy
immediately you're gonna die you would
get murdered immediately unless you got
like some really fast figures exactly
but i will say like that's one of the
things i'm replaying uh red dead
redemption oh undead nightmare style
right oh hello
yeah so fun
zombie style baby it's annoying like
when it's like oh bridge is out and you
can't you just open the bridge
but in this dude it's open the entire
time yeah i love i love games like that
it's like you want to go commit suicide
before
it is your choice yeah go for it your
character's body your choice
that's it i'm not getting political guys
i'm just talking about the characters
yes we're just talking about crackdown
here that's it guys track top three oh
hey bro dude oh he got blown up oh my
god
where is it i think they're up in that
building maybe i don't know what's
happening oh yeah yeah they're right up
there we go there we go oh yeah you're
gonna wanna
oh nice oh sorry uh there is nothing
more satisfying than
like a grounded ground ground pound yet
oh dude oh now you're getting a bunch of
people and people are saying
you need a date yo yup yeah yeah
hey now i can't say that's right
there you go becca needs a date there
you go yeah why is there a barrier if
it's all open well uh cover here we're
only playing the demo here this game
yeah it doesn't come out till november
7th
uh red dead is awesome that's true
that's right
it's just another friday night here at
the microsoft lounge in venice
this happens guys this is what we're all
doing we all meet here every friday we
meet here every friday we play this is
what we do today we decided to stream
exactly we just happened to stream this
time exactly guys is just that happened
to happen 100 stuck in the building yeah
that's what it is
i went out of here
here we go go blow something up then
we're going to let you get back to the
party
guys have you got oh
oh that's it that's it that's it well
played it
man you dude thank you very much where
can people follow you again where can
people follow you at echo k on twitter
echo cancer echo kales on instagram
instagram uh hit me up on that one
business thing that like everyone's like
always like sending emails about you're
like why am i getting emails about yes i
don't want that linkedin link i did a
whole linkedin i did that oh
i love it anyway those other websites
i've been on
follow me on any other weird stuff i
don't know thank you my man thank you
thank you good to see you too
well played
guys about
hey what's going on ellie how are you
come on in i'm aaron say hi to everybody
hi guys wwe diva
uh here we go
all right crackdown 3 have you been have
you played this at all of course i have
of course she has come on now confidence
i love it convention coming in hot here
we go yesterday was my first time
playing it but today was my first time
so you're a day ahead of me you're a day
ahead of me you're day ahead of me let's
get out of here oh oh
[Applause]
did you mess me up no i didn't mess you
up okay get the thing see what happens
all right
so make sure i'm inverted are you
inverted i i hope so
um did you go to e3 this year yes i did
i was there yesterday oh how was it how
was it awesome how did it compare to e3
of years past
here's hints
well
hold on hold on
oh my god you are destroying everything
yes
you just punched that guy's
chest out i think yeah i did i got it
you punched that guy's lungs out of his
mouth that was awesome oh good lord well
my husband works uh two worked out
blizzard when he first met so he's a big
we take that again say that again he
worked at blizzard so he's a huge gaming
fanatic i love it
it shows do you guys have game fights
you guys battle each other in games
she's going to do the
world of dishes but you know that's just
a game you can't really that's dangerous
you know what i can't play those games
because
they're too addictive they're just you
know what i'm saying i i need a game you
can finish and end
those games go on forever it's too
dangerous for me i would just spend the
rest of my life doing it
um you guys crack crackdown three
um
first of all do you like comic books
because this is basically like playing a
comic book actually i should be a female
i'm not a male character but do you want
to switch we can switch you out you want
to switch out no no i'm just kidding all
right it's okay you know you're taking a
walk on the wild side all right
oh there we go what we're ready well
don't worry you're playing echoes game
we're going to start but guess what you
could start with you could start as a
female [ __ ] as a female perfect that's
right i did i did he tried there you go
he thought i was making a mistake
i was like no no
there's 25 of us out there that have the
chance of camera view you guys know that
i started inverting i and then when i
play with conan conan is so bad at games
that he was just like shooting at the
sky so i had to learn uninverted
okay okay i think we need to start it
over
hey
i think we have to start this over
oh yeah i don't know if we can oh wait
yes we can yes we can we're good all
right there we go now you can start as
an email there we go do it do it
leave me alone we got a
i've seen the photos i know amazing yes
wait do you have you have your own line
of hair extensions i do have my home
line of hair how would i
i have my own fashion lines what's your
fashion line called nem fashion so i'm
on instagram
i'm wearing it right now there we go you
look great thank you what do you have
gray extensions could i get extensions
how would i look we have everything
that's the answer you want to hear
natalie that is the answer i want to
hear because let me tell you something
when i grow up my hair it doesn't get
long it just gets like a q-tip it just
gets no you don't have to say it we're
okay
very nice of you thank you but it's just
good i don't know what night you have
like you're not even a silver fox you're
like a white fox
thank you yes um a snow fox
yeah there you go there we go that's
what we're talking about right i like
that
but it does it just gets poofy it just
gets poofy it doesn't get long
you don't want some kind of like hey all
you got to do is clip those bad boys in
and you're good to go yeah there we go
you got some long hair
exactly
where can people follow you on social
media uh you can follow me at natalie
eva murray on all of the platforms oh i
love it
you got that button up
i love it people are like oh like on
instagram i'm flimflam jones but um
like underscore flimflam jones
underscore and then you know sure
everybody and then on friendster
get it done guys if you have questions
this is wwe diva get them in and by the
way i already asked a question about the
gray hair extensions so you don't need
to ask that question i know everybody
was just chopping at the bit we're
playing crackdown three uh i by the way
crackdown the first crackdown was one of
my favorite games of all time
um i love that game because you're so
powerful and in this game you have so
many awesome weapons there's a gun that
shoots a freaking
black hole dude a black i know it's been
a nanotechnology i just did it an hour
ago and i got sucked in the black hole
what well okay that's the danger part of
the black hole gun i will say it's not
the safest gun you know
uh people are saying my hair is perfect
stop it guys i don't i didn't do that
just
come on
that's right
i love it oh luke spawn walker thank you
uh oh there you go exactly hit those
links hit those links in the chat
follow now walker is lying to you
there we go oh my god
uh we're on mixer we're on youtube we're
on facebook we're on twitch we're on
everything tonight uh you're watching
the team coco plus xbox live gaming
event from the microsoft lounge in
venice have you had any of this mystical
drink they're calling the xbox one x
drink tonight you know what i don't even
drink alcohol that's great don't do it
it's terrible for you uh and
you made that choice i made a lot of
i've eaten a lot of tacos in my life
and not great tacos terrible tacos
because of alcohol i would not yeah
exactly don't do it kids
exactly
play games people are saying yes i know
crackdown two i never played but what
you know you can hit that bad boy
exactly right there
thank you to killing it
um so all right so no world of warcraft
i like it no i can't do it maybe maybe
maybe
oh dude just yes what was that a little
grenade action
oh my god are you somebody who in
traffic has road rage you get terrible
because what i love about this game is i
have terrible terrible road rage
and i wish i could do these things
i was just saying earlier i wish i could
get out of my car and just whip it at
somebody there we go we got some bad
boys right up here i know oh
please oh yeah there we go yep yep yep
also if you want to switch to the rocket
launcher you just hold
and you got the old dw oh god oh
goodness that's a lot of okay a lot of
explosions
uh guys stay tuned we're going to be
playing uh
artful escape very soon
and uh we're we're oh we're coming up on
the end of our stream
no around 10 o'clock no i know no don't
worry we're not going to cut you off
please
people are tired of looking at this dumb
puss but they love looking at you
oh we can oh there we go we've got a
logo that said perfect
um
that's right and guys the xbox one x uh
comes out november 7th with this game is
the launch title
crackdown three it's awesome it's really
really fun
it's great it's like grand theft auto
but you have super powers which is
incredible
this is kind of what the movie elysium
should have been did you ever see that
movie matt damon where he gets like the
the big like whatever robo
exoskeleton thing but then doesn't do a
single cool thing with it and it's
totally lame amazing thing this is great
i think you want to run yeah go up
towards those yeah there you go run yeah
i think i want to go up that way past
the fresh food
oh wait there's been this thing so elon
musk said he believes we're all living
in basically a computer simulation do
you believe that that's true do you
think this is all one big video game
no
because sometimes i will say i mean i
don't know but whoever's pulling this
string oh my god
dude you're killing it
i love you're just like a badass in the
street just whipping grenades at people
oh my god
oh god
where are they
dope roll that's how i by the way like
to
when i get out of situations i do a role
in the office you know if i'm talking to
somebody at their cubicle and i'm like
all right i'll see you all later and i
just do like a sweet barrel roll
exactly
that's what i do i love to just roll a
bottle oh you died i died
come on that's right
i love this is friday night thank you
guys for tuning in by the way especially
on the east coast it's lake toast it's
late out there
i love it let's get a sound off in the
chat where are you guys watching from i
want to see
that's right
if life is a video game i need the money
cheat and the rocket pack cheat said
somebody
i don't know i think i would be i don't
no one should give me a rocket pack
if you could do if you have a jet pack
would you use a jet pack i mean i don't
know wait dude i would why not
kidding me i could barely like
walk around without bumping into stuff
the last thing i need is like a jello i
have to say at the convention yesterday
it was quite packed
oh my god here we go nashville texas
germany vegas maine seattle
damn london there we go
you toured all over right you traveled
all over all over that's crazy do you
have any k is like you know
they show some mad love is that true you
could they go bananas over there yeah
i love it that's great what would your
what what is the uk maybe your favorite
place you visited on tour
or maybe you can't pick a favorite i
can't pick a favorite because you know
what that's what's so great is that
every single town yes it's different
that's true
i like that because it's exciting that's
awesome do you have no uh being on the
road for so long do you have any uh tips
for people any tour to do you have a
travel tip that maybe people wouldn't
know
uh
make sure you have multiple chargers
because these phones i just need that in
life by the way i have like one charger
i carry with me everywhere like an idiot
no that is one thing i've learned that's
where we have where am i where am i
that's key uh
one that i would run down there try to
go over have you played this game i
played it for like 10 minutes before we
started oh my goodness i know i got the
thing is like i i only got a chance to
play these games for a few minutes and
everyone has asked me how to play these
games i'm kind of like i don't know run
towards those things
oh there we go here we go
oh yeah dude i think you were a natural
with the jet pack you would be great
i think so by the way as a wrestler
you're like a real superhero anyway well
i appreciate that that's true
i mean without less grenades and jet
packs but still
definitely ass kicking ability for sure
oh my goodness oh god
i will say though one thing if i could
make a quick comment about this game
i would not like to have such a
form-fitting suit i do better with baggy
clothes
oh yeah i like the form fitting because
you get to you know that's because
you're in great shape that's because
you're in great shape for me i like a
garbage bag i like those big uh what are
those huge pants culottes or something
what else called coolants
you know a poncho oh i look great in a
poncho
i will say i'm asking everybody tonight
i want to bring back the cape
would you wear a cape i'd wear a cape
like not ironically yeah guys let's
bring back the cake if i could do one
thing in this stream
besides show you guys some amazing games
tonight it would be bring back the cake
in wrestling
good night new york steve994 none of us
have had the xbox drink yet so we can't
say how it is i know
sorry steve oh my god wait
jvj blaze says your city is boardwalk on
monopoly canada what does that mean
what the internet the internet's crazy
internet
internet craig
the kid can't come back too many work
injuries well look come on not talking
about work capes i'm talking about
pleasure capes fun caves
you know beth is laughing at the fun
capes thing i like the cave idea if i
can make beth laugh that's where we have
a great time uh but we're cape's
definitely not
fine no work capes oh james stephanie
stevens wore a cape in high school there
you go
i wear a cape to the wrestling ring you
did i do oh my god you do that's amazing
see there you go you're you're on the
vanguard the forefront of bringing
kate's back finally there's a lot of
guys
get him get him
run in get get it natalie
you can do it brown and pound that dude
is
definitely extremely rude
oh that's good
come on
guys we're going to be playing artful
escape in a few minutes so stay tuned
what are you saying also what
my power increase yeah dude
level four
i think you should how about you when
you punch that dude's long out of his
face
just you're so powerful in this game
it's awesome
whatever this movie is i love it
oh see
get in there get in there
come on
wait how often what are your workouts
like how i'm trying to get in shape how
often do you work out uh if i if i
wanted to do what you do could i do it
do you think i mean anybody can do
anything
that you know that's a very nice answer
for you that's true but i don't know i
think you have to have some kind of
coordination
[Music]
how are you on the dance floor do you
use any of your wrestling moves like on
the dance floor
you know
i feel like they were transferred
would be a painful thing if that
actually is true
your mom's like please stop me
my mom is only for exactly
exactly
kicking bad guy butts and strutting
that's right that's right that's right
oh my goodness
he's so proud of me right now dude
you're super girl people are saying she
is in this game and in real life
get to kick everybody's ass that's right
uh i think reaper you can glide uh we
were doing it earlier i don't know how
to do it we were doing it earlier
and again this is just oh wow wow that
was quick dude great job thank you so
much killed it girl you killed it let's
bring back the cape let's do it bring
back the cake bring back the cake all
right guys we're going to be playing uh
maybe play a little artful escape thank
you to natalie
oh i know where can people find you you
guys look for me on all social media
platforms at natalie eva marie also be
on the lookout because my first feature
film comes out at the end of the month
june 30th with nicholas page what mickey
whelan dana gershon way to bury the lead
natalie uh we're talking about capes and
you got what's the film called you know
it's called inconceivable what do you
mean by no i'm in the movie well i don't
sorry i don't know i don't know how do
you have to go
i'm just kidding it's called
inconceivable coming to a theater and uh
demand on june 30th i almost got pounded
right you saw i came this close to death
by the way this goes to dad that almost
happened thank you
have a great time at the party all right
uh so again crackdown three november 7th
comes out it's a launch title for the
xbox one x uh and now we're gonna play a
little bit of artful escape which is
great it's a beautiful game
uh
music exploration you guys know i love
some sweet sweet jams uh we've been
hearing some great gems all night you
are watching the team coco plus xbox
live gaming event from the microsoft
lounge in venice uh hey uh o'malley
you wanna wanna get a shot of the party
there what's going on let's get a party
cam going on yeah oh see somebody's
playing crackdown over there that's
awesome
i love it
i love it so let's see
now the question is
which controller it was all right let's
come back here
yeah yeah yeah
what's happening here
oh great
all right ready let's play
so let's go i'm gonna turn the volume
because it's amazing
all right get on in here hello ravel how
are you doing i'm good boss how are you
doing sit down if you would sir i'm
sorry what's up with the old chattaroo
say hi hey i'm raul coley you probably
don't know me
but you
that's right rob buckley he's so ugly
rob earl buckley i know it was we were
really doing him a favor by being on
here but he did do very well
he's a fake gamer he's a what fake gamer
a fake gamer he looks at what i tweet
and one shot and says he's fired shots
fired i love it i love it shots fired so
have you played uh our flick escape
before i haven't though oh fantastic all
right i just played a little bit of it i
didn't want it to be ruined um
so it is a game where you are trying to
unlock and discover your uh inner
musical alter ego so i think david bowie
okay ziggy stardust okay we're gonna
find our own musical alter ego by
playing this game you ready is it
backstreet boys possibly for you it
could be i don't know maybe i'm more of
a hanson
i think my i mean
what is with the face
what is it
first of all handsome
one song
fair enough
name the second song penny and me is
great
i'm actually you know whereas the love
is great uh uh you know i didn't
actually know me myself and i is a great
one i mean look i'll go deep if you want
to they sent me a christmas present last
christmas by the way what yeah we did a
thing with them as a whole thing but i
got a look of their hair oh i wish for
my cloning projects don't tempt me i
mean it was a mug and they were like in
sweaters it was very funny um but anyway
look i love backstreet boys also they're
awesome there's no hate everybody's
great all right fine there's no hype
except for o'malley who's the worst and
he's at the computer sorry sorry about
it
bus thrown under okay here we go let's
play uh so hit a if you would yep
fantastic so violetta is uh i believe
the master i've been written down the
master of lasers
wait i'm going to say it right i'm going
to say it right i'm going to say it
right i'm going to say i believe in you
the greatest later laser artist in the
galaxy that's violeta wow right there
greatest laser artist in the galaxy and
we're going to find out what that means
um it's going to be we're having a
conversation our name is francis
vendetti by the way the coolest name
ever francis vendetti it sounds better
than american accent it does it well
francis vendetti i don't know man
everything sounds good
everything sounds cooler in your accent
it's amazing uh yes you're a team who
goes on a multi-dimensional journey to
create a stage persona okay oh my god
amazing okay great let's go tell me
francis when you're locked away
composing music
oh what are you
i am wow
oh that's a little arrogant that's
pretty arrogant the emperor of dying
stars is more of the humble brag because
they're dying stars yeah that's true but
you're the emperor well played well
played
i love it oh my god
oh there's more here we go waltzing
across the universe of boundless
immensely wow
a mode of dust wandering past the eye if
i knew what moat was i might pick it a
moat it's a it's like it's a piece of
dust it's a fancy word for pizza
a black smoker
exactly black grid you had me at
blackboard
that's the glove we're going to wear i
love it
okay
oh i am boss lady 22. omg i love you
you're an amazing actor one person
people are saying they need to catch up
on their eyes hello tom thumb hello
you look great beard oh thank you you're
the favorite actor out of it dude you've
got a lot of fun what are you talking
about yeah you just got three comments
master of the humble brag i think that's
your level right so we're moving all
right so you're gonna move then you're
gonna if you hit a you jump okay
twice you double jump you hit it three
times you do a sweet thing
awesome this game has i think per capita
the most sweetest guitar solos of any
game i've ever played in my life this is
so tricky it's so cool oh wow look at
the uh
look at that how they love izabe
you're cute you're cute af i'm not going
to say what f means but we all know
fudge fun as [ __ ] you're cute as fudge i
know words i don't know how the lingo
these kids speak
i love it
okay
so i'm traversing so yeah we're kind of
traversing i think we're going to come
to uh you just keep running and we're
kind of exploring this magical
sparkly world it kind of looks delicious
it looks like it's all sugary right
maybe i'm just really hungry i think so
have you tried the tacos i have not
tried it everyone keeps talking about it
no one's i was like house crackdown
how's house um
yeah tacos
that's all anyone's talking about that's
uh i saw them making the little tiny
taco they look great i've just been over
here in the corner
oh here we go
all right so here so here's the thing
okay we're going to uh i think it's
going to tell you to push down on the
right stick down on the right stick all
right we got a guitar now basically that
is b
that's x that's why
i see that's left bumper and that's
right bumper so you got to kind of there
you go okay sorry you gotta do wait
what's why okay okay
don't mind me i'm just gonna do what
you're doing
oh
yes i never knew i was musically gifted
dude you're amazing
can you play any instruments in real
life guitar i'll see oh there we go but
for the purpose of this stream i've
never touched a guitar in my life okay
fair enough and this is making me feel
like i want to play guitar fair enough
that it's doing its job exactly
oh wow whoa what is that thing
that's amazing it's a giant city fish ah
that's great this is a trippy game this
would be awesome to play
like late at night
yeah like right now late at night right
i'm getting closer okay
where are we going
all right so i think you just keep
running to the right i think oh here we
go
oh i'm going to talk to the thing yeah
you got to talk to the big woolly
spiderman thing i think
straight to the point that's what i like
about him exactly
no no uh no hollow balloon no rooney do
no rasmus you just get right into it
let's get right into it
that entrance on the bus goes
okay
[Music]
now uh
okay are you a gamer now are you a gamer
uh normally in life all right great what
are you playing right now what are you
playing right now uh right now i'm
switching between breath of the wild oh
amazing uh pro evolution soccer 2018
because i'm british there we go and i've
about to start wolfenstein because they
never did wolfenstein the reboot yeah
yeah yeah so
that's fine
that's great that's it
that's cool that's another game called
no
i it's n-i-o-h
neo or no it's like
yes yes i heard about that that's
awesome i think that's the correct
pronunciation i'll go with it it sounds
great again everything sounds cooler
with your accent it doesn't matter what
it is
you should narrate this game um amazing
i thought you were always supposed to be
yourself uh that's a lie francis don't
ever believe it francis vendetti whoa oh
this is why she's a laser artist man
okay so it's the same thing again this
this this next so yeah i'm a little
nervous this guy looks kind of rushed
are we battling i think so so you're
going to push down oh there you go you
got it i think it's going to be the same
thing we're going to hit the buttons
am i following this
no i think it's that okay so it's yellow
oh yeah you got it you're on the you're
on you're on the ball you're on the ball
this is joe
we're basically in a in a rock off with
a huge
giant space
mammoth spider wooly mammoth oh my god
oh
i'm improvising now am i not did i do i
don't know i don't know
oh god oh
dude i've had a [ __ ] am i caught
i didn't even see that i think it's
yellow blue red
then left bumper
yeah
that back yellow blue and then together
okay yeah there you go yes
go yep
yellow no i know i messed up it was back
it was back it was bad i got it
it's great you know it's going to help
yeah wolfenstein on the xbox one x looks
the same uh
what is it over there and then there
then there then back to yellow then the
doubles bang i can get this you got this
you got this the internet is watching
that's what's making it intense
mixer i love it here we go oh people are
saying they wish they could play neo
oh yeah
but they shouldn't because it's uh
exclusive to another platform oh that's
true don't play it
what was that the worst
this is a really intense battle by the
i way like
oh yes
this is awesome you guys are like i
think now you're kind of harmonizing
together yeah we have a great light show
this is amazing
[Music]
now what happens i'm all those years of
learning guitar have pain
oh
sassy yeah where are you going
oh yeah let him have it fight me punk
hey settle a little distant what does
that mean
okay
oh no
well you know don't we all i got a lot
of voices in my head you know
they're not all great the people
there we go
let's get to the let's get to the jukes
yeah
this is my favorite bit
i do yeah i like i like games you get to
kind of choose and again like you can
you can um
i believe the name is johnny gal what's
up
johnny galvatron okay so the guy made
this game and he said you you get uh you
can choose all kinds of different it
won't affect the narrative but you do
get different personas depending on oh
that's what you choose okay yes what you
choose yeah so it can be different if
you play it through this like
which is fine this is a matter of fact i
like mine
yeah straight ahead you know
all right well now you don't need to be
a jerk about it you're like harry spider
guy
oh i'm out there we go oh later see it
mate you're like
like right
that's great all right wait when does uh
when does that zombie come back
so we still
we've got like i think two more episodes
air okay uh on tuesdays
and then we're back
next
mid-season wow that's great yeah we
stopped so you get that do you get that
time off do you have to are you gonna go
do another project you know what well so
we've already filmed so i've been off
since yeah we filmed we filmed between
like august and january oh wow great so
i've been in my hiatus oh my what have
you
what's happening
the camera is in the way of the
direction yeah
there we go keep hitting x
jump into the beam jump into the beam
and hit x a bunch
okay okay
hey rizzy
right now
okay cool
okay cool
you guys oh
that was it yeah did you do it no i died
oh you just wanted to look confident oh
my god i was going to say i faked you
out
i don't think i'm saying because i think
have you played because i think they
want us to play a little bit more of a
shadow board you want to play some
shadow ore
that's my i'm shadow mordo is one of my
favorite games you're about to see let's
do that i'm so confident i'm going to do
better than buckley you tell me if i did
that all right
let's just see if i can i want to see if
we can fake it up on this
hey we should start a channel together
we should i'm into this man and a band
by the way because you're really good
and we should say we should call each
other ying and yang yay all right i'm
into it yeah yeah right exactly
i'm 100
this game looks amazing and insane
i feel like my
my persona my musical persona inside of
me is um
like a big penguin right you know a big
penguin that just kind of is it are they
three penguins sort of the same age long
blonde yes yes
yes
the youngest penguin taylor isaac yup
absolutely wait a second yes we're just
describing penguin and bob
but what you know what hanson look the
best boys are great too can you name all
the backstreet boys yeah let's hear it
really yup
nick howie ryan kevin aj
there's only five yeah i thought they're
really yeah see i'm right wait i don't
like your name i can name the n6 as well
i reckon but he had six all of the
nsyncs dude joey fatone was just in our
green room like last week for no reason
for no reason all right i think we're
gonna switch the shadow of the shadow
forward
are you ready escape was amazing artful
escape was incredible
um
joey fatone was just in our green room
right i think he just came for fun right
he was friends with one of the bands oh
he's friends with a lot of the best he's
the star of uh my big fat greek wedding
yeah
there we go
and he was part of nsync that's what
comes after you know what i went to you
ever been to uh sartos in the valley
it's a karaoke place he was there one
time and it was great uh because i was
like oh my god joey futon and then he
sang a song from rent which i believe he
was in
but here's the thing that's kind of like
the song was 20 like 20 minutes long oh
he killed the party well i loved joey
fatone i love you but he's also doing
his profession
it's like
we're not going to play shadow mordor
i'm going to do a monologue
it might not be that one it might be
actually this one oh my god there you go
tricked you tricked you out tricked out
done across the streams this is it's a
separate meta game which controller
controls
so hit b hit b okay
oh am i picking up something here's the
thing man here's the thing
robert did a great job
he
i ruined it because then i got killed
okay um
so it's up to you now you you can't die
we cannot end this stream out of death
we have a stream
no pressure
but you gotta you gotta kill some guys
we're gonna get a big fight because
that's what people want to see yes
that's what people want to see what's he
actually the buttons they want to see at
x x and then oh yeah i don't know the
button
oh my god you holy moly
i was so violent i'm just i'm going
that's all that i feel like i'm going to
fly look at this this is crazy
oh my god italian is just
this is like a clinic
what that was okay
i can get into a bigger fight that was
incredible
oh my
god oh my god dude right
yeah did joey did joey do that i think
so
i think so i want to get into more
fights quick
kill a couple more dudes and we're going
to let you go back to the party
it feels the same but different oh my
god oh as uh then shadow moro yeah
fantastic i mean again
wow
i honestly haven't played this yet i'm
so looking forward to this game well i
would i mean i don't i don't know what
that means i'm the greatest thing i've
ever seen in my life i reckon it's a fun
i've seen children being born on youtube
and that was incredible can you see a
group one big group
yeah that's right make this dream lord
oh yeah kill these dudes
what up
hi fellas
that's my battle cry is that a bad
battle cry
howdy fellas
no i would be i would be so scared well
you know what that's true oh yeah i
wouldn't know what was coming it's the
mark of a serious lunatic like
hey everybody
oh damn
the villains that's why i want to know
oh
dude the villains what are you talking
about these are the villains that were
killing me
they were the killing villains i can't
remember how that's a good bad name for
us get the killing villains i think it's
that is it
i remember the old game that's that's uh
that is um
i believe that's that's
perry
whoa dude
that's a great move oh my god
you know what they need to put for you
and i zombie more uh sword fights
they need to give you more sword fights
than that well i actually played a weird
little like thing for uh yes i play
shadow of mordor in the video in this oh
my god
that was awesome dude this is we're
gonna let you get back to the party that
was incredible oh my god oh my god thank
you so much and where can people find
you on social media uh raul coley13
that's it with the 13 at the end easy
peasy i love it rile thank you so much
man thank you so much
thank you that was good that was the
greatest thing i've ever seen in my life
um
if you guys are just joining us we're
playing shadow of war here at the team
coco plus xbox gaming live gaming party
hey scott what's going on man i'm going
to see you introduce yourself to
everybody scout porterville what's up
everybody he just introduced me
scott porter i love that i'm just like
hey
if that is your real name
um have you played any shadow of war yet
tonight uh not shadow of war tonight but
i did play a shadow of mortar perfect a
couple of years this is the sequel yes
and it comes out october
10th if i'm getting my things right so
uh so it starts right after uh the week
after my mom's birthday oh my god what's
up mom
mom i think i know uh scott's got you
for your birthday yes yes just a week
later
just this typical quarter just a present
for himself a week late for my mom
that's like what i do that's like aaron
blair thing um oh my god all right so
here's the thing uh raul just was
had a clinic just was murdering people
right left i don't know i got murdered
about 50 times i don't believe that at
all i think you need to avenge uh my
death what did you do i got killed by
everybody in that giant fort over there
uh take a
siege yeah
i got just destroyed all right i would
love it if you went in there or if you
just want to hunt no you know what i
found random orcs show i'm going to show
some people something yeah very cool you
know what you're an entertainer
yeah i said i say do what you do best
and that is
wow and amazing just climb this building
here right over and over yes i think i
believe that there's like some cool
story mission stuff yes yeah i want to
go wait you scott you've been in a bunch
of video games correct yes you were uh
peter quill and guardians of the galaxy
telltale you were also in uh batman
telltale games right yes i am currently
uh walking dead you're a little it was
luke in the walking dead fantastic you
get off my building this is my tower
this is my tower i love answering
questions just kicking or they're dead
like this okay all right let's go
uh do i have enough arrows oh yeah oh
someone got an upgrade we got yeah we
got 12 arrows
i think i think uh i think uh michael
the uh
creative director gave us a bunch of
cool stuff oh there we go and i still
wasted it got killed has anybody done
any story i'm just gonna run off no no
one's done any story and if the
opportunity presents itself i might
let's do some stealth kill maybe some
chaining some stealth kills
let's see
let's see oh dude let's see we haven't
seen any stealth kills by the way so oh
this guy's gonna ruin the party dang it
he just ruined everything
it's okay that's okay good lord
it has to be now can you play
is it weird to play games that you're in
is that like destroy do you play the
game or is it that's great that was
great you just fixed that guy's baldness
male pattern baldness you're like here
you go here's some hair
dude get stunned please
get stuck that's a great like
catchphrase out in the world yo bro
get stunned
um is it weird to play games is it weird
to play games that you're a voice in is
that
like distracting do you do that or not
you know what i do play the telltale
games
uh just because
oh come on yes i missed my execution oh
wait hold on let's free this guy come on
dude oh dude you join the fight join the
fight join me oh yeah it's about to get
ugly
yes
yes
here execution
oh wow we're just really going to town
like mike tyson's style i don't know
all right oh carter with the beat down
hold on yeah all right yeah you can eat
this
join me
join me join me you too this is amazing
you come here too and we'll just keep on
doing this [ __ ] now you wear blue
all right
there we go
that is shot of a shadow of war middle
gotham exactly
that's exactly what it is wait what's
with the orcs only in their own beasts
that's a good question why don't works
dress because they got more they got
supplies yes
okay there we go oh wait who's shooting
arrows at me you you can eat it
how about you anybody else want a piece
all right headshot headshot for you head
shot for you oh i missed him god dang it
yeah anyway all right
let's go let's go uh
let's go meet some cool stuff let's go
find some woodland creatures dude game
on woodland creatures yeah um i gotta
say too i love arkham knight he's amazed
like you know you're the voice of
nightwing i was nightwing in that uh i'm
robin and injustice ii yes i haven't
played that yet but i hear it's insane
it is insane it's totally nice
i am in the new story mode of madden
if it's in the game i'm in the game whoa
there we go i am in the game that's
really cool
all right let's see this
a strange music
double-changed music to the force
it's time to answer the call
dubstep draws youtube
what is that what is that weird dubstep
i hear
all right let's see what's up
let's go garden action let's go
yeah let's go
so this is uh
trying to remember the names i know
keller bimbore is the uh it feels very
this is very spooky i'm not happy with
this i get spooked easily i don't like
ground mist as a general rule
in life because i saw thriller when i
was a kid too early
oh this guy's all messed up
tell me what you saw show me what you've
seen oh [ __ ] oh my god oh my god
this is crazy all right like i'm in the
evil i'm just glad we have some titles
on because i cannot yes i literally
drake's in the background
oh that seemed unnecessary
that was not cool dude
why do that
uh-oh people said injustice 2 is doping
robin's a punk in the game what are you
talking about oh eat it that's fight
words eat it yeah whatever you know what
people i didn't say brown mist i said
ground this jeez come on chat get your
mind out of the gutter but also brown
mist is gross people who can't take
layers don't like robin because exactly
you know there's like three different
movies i agree i agree like three
different levels of moves for robin
people loving injustice too oh yes
the first one was awesome you couldn't
save lois or anybody yeah
there you go crazy
yo i'm just gonna be
oh
dude you're just popping heads good
where is this trail here cool oh there
okay
there it is you looking around oh that's
something interesting oh wait oh wait i
found him
oh here we go
yeah you always got to look for clues on
where you're supposed to go i love this
man this is great we haven't played much
of the story mode of shadow war yet
oh
stop it
yeah dude
you are just a surgeon
yeah oh that's you want to do this
do you want to do this
are you sure are you sure oh my god oh
my gosh
eat it oh my god dude i don't think it
gets much better than that
i think we're gonna have to let you go
back to the party man thank you dude
that was incredible hey how am i gonna
do anything scott porter everybody where
can people find you on social media
scott find me on social media at scott
porter on twitter at skittishkid on
instagram s-k-i-t-t i-s-h-k-i-d
uh and go play a game that i'm in uh
near you which won't be hard because
he's in all of them so if it's in the
game i'm in the game
i love it thank you scott thank you oh
my god that was incredible
how did we do that such an experience
right now
here we go i missed it
scott got us off on a good note
everybody
so i can't ruin this i have to live up
to scott's legacy
and he's set here we go get some arrows
guys are almost on our stream so
uh
yes
locking the nightwing stuff ah here he
is mr zachary levi everybody how are you
good to see you say hi to the chat oh
what's up jenny james
wait have you played shadow of war have
you played any of this oh you're blonde
wait a second wait a second
covering up the lead here frank i'm
blonde guys nice i like it how long have
you been covering up the leaf that's
right well you were buried news
reference yeah
it wasn't burying so much just blonde my
whole
uh no i i just said i shot a movie up in
vancouver you've changed man blonde is
changing i know it's really dangerous
uh
shot a movie in vancouver to the psych
movie that'll be out in christmas
yes have you played any of this i'm not
here tonight all right uh a is gonna run
x is attack
uh um okay y is gonna parry yeah uh
there's creatures everywhere
and then the creature is out for your
body tyler perry how do you know why i
think you you make a lot of shows and
just make a ton of money
yeah we're roaming around okay we're
finding things i think yeah you know
what actually one's indicator yeah yeah
objective guys do you like how you had a
yellow wow this guy i told you exactly
the wrong thing you're like are we what
are we doing i'm like just running
around you're like oh wait there's a
mission i'm like yes swim in that
yellow guys we got some questions for mr
zachary levi i have no answers he has no
answers no he's already answering mary
and oh i just like jumped over a root
how long were you in vancouver i loved
that city i was in vancouver for a
couple of weeks wait
very already way to get over that stuff
you were like
wait what i feel like it's above me now
what is happening no no you're good i
think you want to go are you following
the trail so follow the trail so it goes
kind of straight like this oh no no no
no no no no it's not this way though is
that the ch is that oh yeah is that it
oh is that the thing yeah i think you
want to go yeah oh you already made it
oh i got that though how do i get that
[ __ ] it's the mist you're following the
mix how do i get these these arrows i
think you just walk out you're full you
twelve out of ten oh i got full arrows
he's got full arrows guys i'm fully
arrow you don't walk around with like
half [ __ ]
three arrows you got the twelve air oh
here you go
here we go
you're gonna have to there's
interrogate this fool we're gonna see
what he saw we're trying to solve what's
going on in the old woods
yeah dude
i found a founder the tree she's the
tree oh boy it's an evil tree spirit of
canal the stream beast
bang and claw rooting spear i wish you
were at my apartment to narrate every
game i played yeah it's incredible
oh i love it
i love that what a move but but what
voice am i going to narrate it in the
you know should have been michael cohen
more questions than great truth
that was horrible it makes every that
makes every game just soothing he's just
investigate the great tree oh
in a bond movie was blonde you could be
in uh living daylights living daylight
wasn't he blonde wasn't he was ever
walking was it a bond movie yes he was
in like the living daylights or
something like the 80s i feel like i
just grew up i
is that what i've been waiting for these
36 almost 37 years was just that by the
way i think grace jones or i might have
had a stroke just now
i might have had a stroke no no
exactly no
oh my god oh finland says
finland loves you they say hi no oh
finland finland yeah i love you too
oh they're talking over there
trees
great walking they like your they like
your walking guys
that's right
that's right this guy's everywhere
oh it's about to go down people say
thank you i'm nervous
yeah there you go look at that see
blonde walking dude that's good
that's great i love it that is tripping
yeah
oh my god so this is the guy super
dude
intense
some time in the sun bro
jeez
what is that powder oh
powder is yours
oh this is not going to be good
what do i do bb
oh that was aggressive
that was unnecessary that was
unnecessary oh all right well it's been
fun
it's been super fun
thank you very much
thank
everybody is legit and very real where
can people follow you because there's
consequences to this game you can't just
roll up on a tree that turns into a big
dog exactly while your powder friend
talks to you in the air
you need to pay attention to the button
controls that'll you can find me on
zachary levi and basically oh here he
comes again oh you're so scared
so screwed this is not for me
oh you fending them off there we go my
my b button skills were just not very
important there we go i don't know what
to do now thank you sir bless you
awesome thank you very much and god
bless you leave everybody zachary levi
thank you so much amazing
the blonde really unlocked the michael
kane in him i feel like
[Music]
um again shadow of war guys
the uh this game comes out i believe
october i want to say october 10th i
want to say october 10.
i'm just owning this i feel like you
know what everybody who we played with
tonight
what's that
october 10th everybody who played with
tonight scott rubble everyone robert
i've been playing this game have really
inspired me
and i feel like all of a sudden i'm
getting way better
um guys i think
i'm just gonna just i wanna kill one
thing please in this stream i know we
have to end i just wanna just let me
have one thing please in my life yes i
did it that's it
that's it
we did it guys thank you so much for
tuning in to the team coco plus xbox
gaming event this is super fun uh
if you
missed any of this you can watch it uh
at
you can watch it on youtube you can
watch it on twitch.tv teamcoco uh
tonight we played artful escape we
played crackdown 3 which comes out
november 7th along with this bad boy the
xbox one x that's right look at this
thing by the way this is insane look at
like the this is crazy it's crazy town i
love this thing it's amazing uh
it's extremely sexy and it's super small
by the way it's smaller than the xbox
one x which is like how did they do that
i think there's some kind of crazy lord
of the rings wizardry in here there
might be a ring of power in here uh but
this comes on november seventh and uh of
course shadow of mordor comes on october
10th
and forza comes out october 3rd uh and
xbox is awesome games are awesome you
guys are awesome thank you for joining
us thank you to everybody who stopped by
and we will see you
soon good night
you